guess what guys you can now have your
very own set of little baby men yeah
look at ricky look at that and you can
have them all in a little trash taste
plushie bag as well so if you want to
get your very own little baby man and
trash taste plushie to go with it make
sure to smash that link in the
description down below
it's only been a week i've forgotten how
to start this [ __ ] because you haven't
got your rubik's cube review do i have
to hold it
what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
joey and i'm with gun connor as always
and we haven't done an episode in a week
and i already forgot how to start one of
these i don't know it feels like it
feels weird because even though well
you've done a lot this past week
but i took like a nice little like
three-day break yeah and then for some
reason like do you ever go
do you ever do you guys ever feel like
if you get off the grind for just one or
two days you just forget how to work
yeah right
i come back home and i'm like all right
and then i just sit on my desk like oh i
i get more motivated to get back in the
grind i'm like i'm like doubly charged
oh no i get that sometimes as well but
like if it's especially after like a
long because you know we've been on the
grind for quite a while now because
we're you know preparing for the tour
yeah you know which i guess by the time
this episode has gone up we should have
finished by now yeah i think but as of
us right now we're still preparing for
the tour so we have to make a crapload
of episodes for you guys um
and it's been you know really busy month
and then suddenly because of connor's
thing we're just like all right uh you
got a week off and i'm just i remember
like the first day i was like what do i
do
i i it's isn't it sad i've almost
forgotten
how to take a day off yeah because i i
told myself okay i'm gonna take a day
off yeah in reality i did not take a day
off yeah i just worked less because like
what happened is uh since since we've
been back from like you know just uh
convention season and everything like
that we've had to like film basically
four episodes a week we get like one
episode one stream then another two
episodes another day um and then connor
connor yeah that's three i guess
basically
i think i
i mean technically technically a stream
is an episode because that goes into the
afternoon you know okay four episodes so
i counted those four episodes
but uh you know connor did something
incredible you know congratulations to
you gg's [ __ ] 300k gig a chatbot it's
gonna be out like ages from now yeah i
know
just just to just to date this episode
then i guess because they'll be like
when is going to talk about it i guess
seven episodes later it's like wow all
right connor's like not talking about
this this is weird like it's kind of
wrong
yeah and then so we had like a week off
trash taste and as soon as as soon as as
like that was like i guess announced
yeah sydney was like we're booking
something we're booking something now
fill up the schedule
this is this is our time now so uh fair
enough so yeah we went away your side
job kicked in
my marriage kicked in
my third my third time i have no excuse
now
like what are you doing ah again [ __ ]
and uh so yeah we uh take a nice few
days off and then i don't know why
because i feel like with holidays
there's like there's like a perfect time
where i'm able to like recharge reset
everything i feel like that's a week i
need to take like a week off yeah in
order to like get like the grind
back you know get like the motivation to
get to grinding again if it's like one
or two days i've noticed with like the
youtube grind it's just it
throws you off your
schedule or throws off like this
momentum that you have i don't know it's
really weird for me do you have like a
schedule every day
i um now that i have like a second
channel and streams and stuff i actually
do
first time
okay first time it's almost like it's a
real job
it's weird having a schedule now just uh
just waking up and being like oh [ __ ]
i've got stuff i need to do and uh it's
it's it's weird this this has been a
very weird time for me guys and i'm like
transitioning and i'm transitioning i
remember when i was just like one
channel is like more than too much one
channel is too much and now it's just
about placing your efforts in the right
place you know you know make sure you're
working on the things that you need to
be working on yeah yeah exactly yeah i
don't know it's also just
i i find it easier to work on things i'm
passionate on so
when i'm passionate when i'm passionate
then i find it hard to concentrate on
anything else so what happens your
second channel when you get like bored
of gentian you're just like did you
disappear all content vanishes all right
all right guys i just i just delete the
channel
taking a break i'll see you guys when
they update the game yeah
you know i haven't thought that far
ahead but maybe by the time this video
goes if i can't diversify it's it's it's
weird because like i'm like in my in the
back of my mind i'm like i know i need
to diversify i should make it here
but also i'm just addicted to playing
gentian so i'm like either either i
don't play it uh either i don't stream
it i'm playing or i stream it and play
it well you can't quit now because
you're literally the biggest gentian
streamer on twitch
who gets more views i don't know i mean
you're pulling some pretty crazy numbers
he keeps growing right now the numbers
and uh i don't know i don't know because
all the games and players are like
finally some fresh meat
you guys want to join in you guys no no
people stream gotcha and they're like
man this growth is awesome and then they
get your point like wait hold on i don't
play this game anymore can you guys
still stick around they're like see ya
they're gone then everyone's like wait
why wait wait you weren't watching for
me
it's all good it's all good
will release the next game and then uh
that's that's uh that's more free
content
i'm still related i'm still waiting for
the star rail release
yes thank you for the next game thank
you thank you you're like that meme of
like the guy feeding the creation
thank you for the content thank you for
the content
other games do not exist
oh man well i guess uh do you want to do
you want to talk about your your
achievement then yeah i i feel weird
being i don't want to i hate it when
you're like congratulating me
congratulations
as selfless as it was selfish i didn't i
did a lot of the reason i did it because
i wanted to do it yeah oh yeah
because i i'm not going to sit here and
be like dude i just wanted to do a
charity event this i just wanted to do
this and i was like oh wait this makes
perfect sense to be a champion
you know what i mean like i feel like
a lot of the times some events come
along you're like this just makes way
more sense it's gonna be more fun for
everyone it's gonna be way better if
it's not just for me yeah yeah yeah
because it's like all right you know i i
i thinking back i'm like how could it i
said i should probably explain what i
did yeah i was about to say it's
probably been a while i'm sure
i'm sure we should be watching this now
i cycled across hokkaido with chris
um
seven hundred and fifty kilometers or
something whoa nice
over five hundred miles and how much uh
how much did you raise you raised over
three hundred and sixteen thousand
dollars nice
and deficiency foundation oh yeah
[ __ ] incredible i mean two things
that shocked me when i saw that tweet
about when you guys finished one was
obviously the amount of money
which is crazy yeah two the fact that
chris survived yeah yeah yeah yeah well
so you know obviously spoiler alert
chris is going to come on the podcast
again so i'll i'll talk about it mainly
from like i suppose my perspective and
the stuff that i was dealing with
because right i'll let chris talk about
the other stuff oh how he dealt with his
mother i mean you know chris's credit on
the on
later days chris is doing better than me
i was really yeah i mean i was like
powering through the first few days i
was doing great chris was having a
miserable time yeah yeah and then you
know
a lot of the time with cycling and stuff
like you learned you learn a lot of
things when you do it days in a row like
i feel like the shin nami kaido we
didn't actually learn anything about
cycling no of course not because you
just do it and you're done and like you
could you can you could cycle for a day
with a [ __ ] bike and not know like cause
all of our seats and everything was
completely well we learned how not to
cycle yeah
her number one comment on the on our
cycling special was like you guys know
like your seat was too we didn't know no
we did we did we know nothing about
we're not cyclists yeah and you know
like so like to put it into perspective
like the shin nami kaido uh the thing
that we did was like 75k yeah but we
might as well have done it on a tricycle
yeah yeah yeah it was literally a clown
bike
yeah and like
i think on average we were doing 100
plus kilometer days
like every single day and there's like
one day we did like 65 but even then
like
the weather conditions changed the
cycling right right because you guys are
up in the mountains and you know i feel
oh yeah it changes all the time right
and then i got this [ __ ] backpack on
my back so i i i you know when i
quit because the reason why this
happened i'm sure we'll talk about this
even more again when chris comes on
chris was you know lamenting to me about
how he wants to get fit and stuff and i
was like bet let's actually do something
like let's let's do something like let's
do something crazy yeah uh and i was
like i really want to go to hokkaido
again because why the [ __ ] that's
i just love hokkaido honestly i think
it's my favorite favorite yeah
it's awesome
i i wanted to do something that would be
pretty tough yeah so i thought that
cycle again like on a map i think about
this i'm like 500 miles like easy i can
do that because like
cycling is tough but ultimately
if you just wake up early it's not that
hard
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait no no i
don't know what i'm saying is
if you want to do site like cycling
cycling like you want to get places and
like actually do it good yeah you you
don't have to wake up that early so what
you're saying is secret to winning tour
de france isn't about training
there is like you can cycle and you can
cycle at a pace that pretty much uses
like your
you don't go out of breath you don't
really use your muscles that much it's
kind of like your natural rhythm
resources
yeah you just your natural pace that's
comfortable for you on like a flat road
that will get you to your place if
you've set a reasonable distance like
yeah i was going to ask like were the
majority of the roads flat
well i mean i'm sure there were some
inclines yeah i mean sometimes you get
lucky and it'd be flat but then i mean
like i'm talking like because my only
other point of reference is the shimon
amikaida right yeah i mean there was
some brutal hills i mean like you've
you've driven on the roads in japan
right yeah sometimes the roads just
don't end yeah yeah and they go up like
there was the worst one we had a few
really bad ones but the worst one was it
was um seven kilometers just uphill
right
you can imagine yeah how long that took
and then it was like seven kilometers
downhill which is like [ __ ] epic and
then you're like this is the best thing
ever yeah because it just does it
literally just doesn't stop right but
it's crazy because like that kind of
like elevation it's like we've started
at the ocean and as you're you're
climbing up at some points you can see
the ocean and you are crazy high up
right right i think it was like uh
it was like 500 meter
incline yeah yeah which is just like
crazy yeah you can just like bike up
that i don't know i learned a lot i
learned that your bike seat height
matters a lot
i had mine um so because you have to oh
dude as well another thing that i i
guess that would be fun to talk about
dude trying to get your bike
like transport it yeah is a nightmare
really well because how do you how do
you oh yeah because i guess you get bike
on a plane
is it just over-sized luggage it's in
like the special luggage okay so you
just like go up to the counter and but
you have to pack your bag which is a
nightmare yeah you have to pack the
bicycle um like so chris i was lazy and
i bought a bag that you just take the
front wheel off it's super [ __ ] easy
you just
comes off and then you strap everything
in place right and i think to get on the
plane a a recommended deflating the tire
so it doesn't pop yeah yeah yeah i don't
think it'll actually like pop though but
i i just did it anyway yeah yeah and
then you will shove it in a bag i'm
vastly overestimating this it took like
an hour to do this and you get oil
everywhere it's so [ __ ] i hate this
and then you just check it in and then
the whole time on the plane you're
panicking because you're like this is a
carbon fiber bike it's going to break
and it's like everything's going to
[ __ ] go wrong right it's [ __ ]
terrible and even then like going back
before that it's like all right i don't
i don't own anything to cycle um do you
want anything to cycle well not since
the schumann army kaido but we bought
like the shittest shittiest amazon
basics yeah yeah yeah yeah that was just
like
how cheap can we go to sleep
because it's because it's still padding
on my ass
aren't the exercise bikes like really
well padded i mean
they are but like you know if you're on
that thing for like an hour or two which
i usually am yeah then like after a
while you're just like [ __ ] man my look
i've got no meat on my ass all right so
after a while it just like goes directly
to my bones and i'm just like my pelvis
is screaming because you have to get
used to that yeah of course
you're also like dummy thick back there
yeah yeah i think it makes it worse
though
music
what okay so like this is because we
again i mentioned offhandedly to chris
so like i guess i'll go through the
timeline oh yeah this is interesting i
don't know if it isn't whatever i
mentioned to crystal like let's do this
i want to do this why the [ __ ] not yeah
and i thought like chris would say no
because you know when you have a crazy
idea and you're like it's crazy if i say
it to someone and they say no
immediately yeah because then you're
like okay i guess it is crazy but if you
say a crazy idea to someone they're like
okay
you're like oh
maybe it's not that insane right maybe
we can like do this yeah and so i was
like you get a video i'll live stream
the whole thing
i didn't know and then he was like yeah
sure let's do it and then i was like
wait [ __ ] what if is there signaling
like whack-a-night cause i remember when
we drove yeah there was no signal in
some parts i was like wait [ __ ] can i
actually do this wait how do i keep
everything cool wait how do i run it for
10 hours in a backpack i need to buy a
bike how do i charge my phone like how
do i read chat
i also want to do this thing it was just
like
i agreed to do it and then there's a
billion things i had to figure out yeah
and it was just oh my god it was awful
awful i didn't know how to buy anything
i didn't know what to buy
who just i don't know anyone who cycles
in japan yeah so i just started asking
around these great guys who've been
helping me with a lot of irl streaming
stuff i just kind of messaged hey how do
i um
how do i how do i check if i can stream
in this place and they were like oh just
go check out like cell towers so i i'm
like yeah sick i open up a map of cell
towers that's like none right it's like
for like three days there's like no cell
phone towers they're like all right but
maybe maybe if you like go along this
really specific road and stay on this
road you can do it but you need to go to
docomo and get like docomo sims yeah
yeah so docomo is like the old
government cell phone company so a lot
of the rural areas in japan uh are
mainly like docomo yeah i was like [ __ ]
okay right so now i gotta go and get two
more phone contracts and buy two new
modems and figure out how that's gonna
happen and then i was like wait my my
bag is like [ __ ] for cycling so i asked
like rob rob dc great streamer he helped
me out came to my house told me what to
buy
dude rob is a go so i actually got the
idea from rob yeah because he did a
cycling thing as well yeah again it's
going even more back rob did a stream
where he cycled across japan for like 30
days i think it was from tokyo to kyushu
somewhere and like back and back yeah
he's he's he's actually a madman yeah
yeah he you know because he was a
cyclothon subathons every time somebody
saw the sub the thing went higher yeah
yeah and i was like i don't wanna do
that yeah i just wanna like i just wanna
like do this
give me a beginning and end point yeah
yeah yeah so that's that's what we did
and you know
credit to him really nice guy helped me
out with it a bunch because you know a
lot of people are like hey i kind of
want to did what you did can you give me
advice and help me out a lot of people
would be like no no that's my idea don't
steal that yeah
and so he was like he's you know
super helpful we did even help me do
like a test stream
we tested the bag out it did not work
properly it was like overheating right
the next day he was like dude don't
worry i got you i'll come over we'll
install a fan in your bag yeah so we we
installed a pc fan in my bag
to cool my bag so you're basically
carrying a towel i'm literally carrying
like you've got a pc tower yeah
yeah like i'm carrying like and again
another another problem it's like i have
this like it's just every time i would
do something that's how stressful it was
just another problem would come up yeah
of course okay so i have this bag with
four modems uh live broadcasting tool
and now it's got a pc fan how the [ __ ]
do i power all this i had a really big
battery it turns out that really big
battery can't go on the plane to go to
wakana so then i have to call up the
hotel and i'm like hey can i ship some
stuff to your hotel right and they were
like yeah all good so that was all okay
problem i'm avoided yeah how did you buy
a new battery like a 300 battery 50 000
milliamp battery it's like it's
literally the one thing it's the [ __ ]
uh camping one right right right right
it's like it's the thing
five kilograms yeah and it's like [ __ ]
this is on my back
and it's like all right okay so so we
have all these problems so i had to lay
everything out in the bag like with
velcro so it's all evenly distributed so
that it's not just weighing me down and
killing my back yeah yeah yeah perfect
done so then i'm like all right i need a
bike
[Music]
i'm telling you man one of the hardest
things on earth is trying to figure out
a good bike yeah online it is like when
you look online it's like what is good
bike and it's literally like i bought
this tour de france bike for fifteen
thousand dollars it's pretty good but if
you're a more budget option we've got a
9k bike here for amateurs and it's like
what the [ __ ] is any of this like
literally every time i try and buy a new
camera yeah it's like cyclists are so
like insular with their like suggestions
and stuff yeah yeah yeah you know these
sunglasses they kind of deflected the
micro wind uh you know in like a 0.3 you
know and the uv with the 0.3 speaking
english it was just like i just didn't
understand anything yeah about cycling
yeah and there's a guy called josh in
japan who was really great and he helped
me out and he basically he cycles a ton
in japan he just gave me all the
suggestions told me to what pence to
bought i bought new cycling pants that
had like uh straps straps that went over
they were they were awesome they were
great i like didn't chafe at all it was
great they stayed up all the king was a
pain in the ass because i have to tip my
shirt off every time i want to pee
again it was so expensive because i
bought like a pretty good bike right
yeah yeah i bought a bike it was called
cannondale synapse 3l it's like a 4 000
bike all right yeah i was like
government if you're listening i'm never
riding it ever outside of this one
charity event um so it's a tax write-off
please please but yeah so it was just
like a month of crazy prep and getting
everything ready yeah yeah just hoping
like how do you test this like i can't
go to wakana in the middle of nowhere in
hokkaido and test if this works yeah
exactly so like i'm [ __ ] myself yeah
and i'm in like in basically like sudo
russia in japan you're in the middle of
nowhere and like just day one you're
like you turn everything on and you just
hope it works and yeah some things broke
right away and you're like [ __ ] like our
tires we didn't like inflate them
properly and then
um stuff wasn't working and i had to um
so another thing is that it was for
charity yeah and i wanted there to be
text to speech on my speaker for all the
donations coming through so i thought
that would be fun yeah incentivize
people and also i'm gonna be cycling
like all day like nine hours but i have
something to keep your mind occupied
yeah my mind like numb yeah and um so
like turns out that
uh the charity service i was using
tiltify
just doesn't let you do text-to-speech
in any way really there's no way you can
do text-to-speech with it uh through
like stream labs yeah yeah yeah um
stream elements anything it doesn't work
and uh so shout out to stream elements
and my uh one of my mods i just asked
someone's like hey could you make
something you should program something
that will read text-to-speech so both of
them made things so stream elements just
made a
plug-in just for this charity event wow
so that i could have charity donations
come out on the speaker right in like
three days shout out to them
so many people helped like yeah like my
mod who's just uh rode who's awesome who
manages our subreddit as well he made
like a live tracking thing
yeah i saw that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i i i can't really use this in day
like normal streams i don't want
everyone to know
[Music]
yourself it's literally like doxing
where i am like yeah yeah yeah in real
time yeah right um make sure you don't
accidentally show that next year
but it's sick though right because it's
like i thought like okay
again like another issue is like how
how do you make nine hours of cycling
engaging yeah because like that shit's
boring like i i wouldn't watch it yeah
but it's like okay so you have you have
the narrative of the the charity and the
challenge right and and the journey
that's one but that's that's not really
like like you if you if you missed day
one you maybe you don't care about that
as much yeah it's like so i was like
okay i really want to have some kind of
like progress bar or tracker on the
screen yeah uh and i just you know three
weeks before the event i asked my mods i
was like hey can you can we try and make
something and yeah they made it it took
it was like pulling hair testing this
app it was like every night they were
like we tested again and i just sat
there for an hour and they were like
type this on android editor and i was
like dude
it's broken it doesn't work
like hours and hours hours yeah took so
long but then you get this cool result
where you get this progress bar that
tells you how far i am from the
destination a little monkey on the map a
little animation that was a custom app
that was made yeah yeah it was a custom
app called find my monkey that they made
wow um it was like literally like every
morning before the cycle i would zoom in
on where i was put start zoom out go to
where we're going to finish put end yeah
and it would just do like a geographical
straight line yeah which wasn't like
perfect because sunday's people would be
like wow what an easy day we have 60 but
then the root was like this yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it was actually like 120
and we're like wow he's moving so slowly
but luckily we had like a speedometer as
well right which was using gps to show
how fast i was going which is also fun
because then chat was like oh my god
he's moving at like 50 kilometers an
hour on this downhill everyone's getting
hyped yeah it was just like
trying to like gamify it and trying to
make it like engaging i think that it
worked yeah people already liked it like
views were crazy for me yeah yeah
exactly i saw you peek to like 30 000 at
the end yeah
41 or something like that i've never had
that many viewers ever on a live stream
yeah yeah and that's nice that's [ __ ]
insane yeah it was it was crazy it was
uh it's hard though because cycling with
the backpack on it was like it was a lot
and then also trying to like be fun for
nine hours cycling is hard yeah yeah
yeah for sure um that was hot that was
hardest part i felt like some days i
wasn't engaging enough
at that point i think there's enough
elements within the stream that you
didn't need to be engaged no one's gonna
blame you for that yeah yeah dude i
think for the first like four or five
days i was killing it with the
engagement i thought i was like just
talking non-stop even though cycling
yeah um except for like uphills i was
like all right chat just
but even that was fun because like i i
think i think it all worked really
nicely where we had enough elements in
it um where everyone kind of came
together
and when like uphill sections happened
that were really long everyone was just
kind of like in cheering mode and that
was really fun
it was just everything worked like i was
very lucky that
we never had a signal outage more than
like 20 30 minutes right and even then
most of them were like one minute right
right yeah yeah yeah so yeah it worked i
i don't know it's i think it's a [ __ ]
miracle that all worked out yeah i don't
know the battery lasted every single day
i i
my i had a 50 000 milliamp battery and
it only
died on the very very last day after 10
hours of streaming damn with four things
plugged into it god damn okay and then
it would last like another hour on like
residual charges right right so that's
like crazy yeah i'm i i'm yeah it was
nuts i didn't even talk about how like
how the cycling actually was just the
prep and doing it was hard yeah that was
hard yeah because like like i saw how
many things you had going on in like irl
stream setup and everything like that
and i was just like is this custom made
or is this like all that was like custom
yeah yeah god damn gg so like how much
time did this play like take like
planning to like execution
um
like a month or so we had about a month
between when i pitched the idea and when
we did it and even then like we were
changing
the route kind of like whilst we were
cycling as well
like because google maps
just like there was if you cycle in
tokyo there's pre-existing cycle routes
yeah yeah that can tell you where to
cycle but in wakanda and stuff like that
no one cycles there
we didn't see people no one's there well
no one's there period
like after we left wakana we just didn't
see people for like four days yeah
there was nothing yeah and um
like
it was just
so much prep so much and like i was
trying to do work and do other streams
whilst also trying to manage everything
and also i didn't really promote it that
much right i was kind of like yeah it's
happening and in hindsight i should have
promoted it way more because i'm like
this is like eight days i should have
promoted this yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
but i was also terrified that if i
promoted it too much and then the first
day and the first day just had no signal
right because i i genuinely thought like
the first day of cycling i would just
have no signal for half the day right i
kept telling the viewers as we were
leaving work and i'm like listen
if there's no signal for like two hours
i'm so sorry it's probably going to
happen just just deal with it yeah and
it was like terrifying because you're
like man
it really [ __ ] sucks to have your
first day of in a big event yeah just
not work and the technical issues how do
you convince people to then just you
know stick around yeah if they don't if
they don't invest themselves in the
first day a lot of people are going to
fall off yeah yeah yeah yeah because
what happened is it was kind of like a
like that in viewership right right the
first day was crazy we had like 27 000
viewers right i don't even know why
like the people were going crazy like i
think all our energies were really high
as well because the first day yeah chris
was chris was really really funny the
first day and was energetic slowly went
[Applause]
down same with me to be honest i mean
for the first five days i was killing it
and then i started really slowing down
right um and yeah and so
i've got the questions
how was your how was the experience well
that was it this was tough preparation
for the hardest part like getting all
the the widgets and stuff to work
but like that's why i did like two days
before i did a
test stream in tokyo yeah where i did a
60k cycle across tokyo but obviously
it's not really like the same because
tokyo is like perfect internet yeah like
there's never worry that it would cut
out because like tokyo has like it's
like mcdonald's everything irl streams
just work it because it works so well in
tokyo you really have to be like
in like a weird basement or some kind of
room that's made of aluminium foil yeah
exactly i said aluminium ew
no no no you said it right you said it
right you said it right connor
wasn't a mistake in that i don't know i
was gonna say aluminum
aluminium it's aluminum
he's been indoctrinated
uh yeah i'm sure there'll be like a
really big video out i don't know if i'm
gonna do one or two parts or whatever
yeah but like it was it was a lot of
prep it was so i wish i could show the
prep because the prep was crazy and like
right
shout out to my uh my uh uh mods and
slash programmers
who uh worked
really [ __ ] hard on making the farmer
monkey app i think that was the coolest
part for me yeah yeah i think watching i
mean you just had a custom map
it was i thought it was [ __ ] sick
that you could just
see like the map it was zooming in and
out gradually showing you where i was
and yeah like kind of go i just thought
they were sick and a progress bar like a
progress but that's so [ __ ] cool when
i watch the tour de france i'm like
where are they i don't [ __ ] where's
the progress ball
dude tell me the tell me that give me
the progress bar man that's what i need
what's that like actual current speed on
a gps yeah give me like i want like look
like make it like a game yeah make it
like i'm just i won't watch tour de
france unless there's a hud
i i had like a heads-up display right
like if two of the friends had chat
i'm i'm watching that yeah you know what
i mean two of the friends needs this
dude i like you know what i want like
the hearts
it's so [ __ ] weird because um because
i i've also been streaming more often
than past months i'm trying to try to
dabble in more often i'm kind of getting
used to it right
but then like a few days ago i had to
like stream like a let's play yeah and i
was like great this this can be easy all
right i've been doing let's plays for
this past month yeah and everything like
that yeah and just like but it was like
an offline let's play so no chat just an
og offline let's yeah and i i tried i
tried like i thought it was going to be
easy because i was like i've been
streaming like i've been streaming games
streaming different things like almost
like every day for like the past month
whatever this is going to be easy i turn
on the game
and i like subconsciously look towards
where the chat is i see no interaction
i'm like
what the [ __ ]
is everything better and i just i
actually had to like scrap the video
because i was like i i don't know how
yeah i actually don't know how to like
commentate or like be entertaining
you know what's so weird though i
actually find it easier when there's no
chat no no no no because i because early
in my channel i did let's plays yeah
that weren't on stream right so like i
because i'm used to that from early on
in my channel because i was a one point
a let's player yeah i just find it so
much easier when there's no chat for me
for me chat i i'd be i might be thinking
about like uh you know something you
know like okay i'm gonna say like this
joke here yeah like you know explain
this or whatever yeah but while i'm
doing that on stream because i'm so
engrossed in looking at chat i all the
jokes just fly out of my head so i
become such a boring let's play on
stream i just read out the funniest
thing chat says and i just say say as if
it's my joke
so that normally works really yeah
to me like i i think my big issue is
that when i don't have when i'm not live
streaming and when am i just trying to
record like an offline video second
channel video whatever um i like think
about what i say too much yeah so i try
i try to like script it in my head you
know what i mean whereas if i have you
generally yeah yeah yeah i turn into
like giggup right whereas if chat's
there i'm forced to say what's the first
thing that comes to my mind right i
don't i can't like second-guess myself
so i just haven't forced like constantly
talk i'm like a firm believer that
as a streamer your chat should be on
screen i just think it always should be
on screen oh yeah of course i just think
that like that's the whole live element
right show them like it doesn't have to
be like crazy not like nico nico where
it's like flying across the [ __ ]
screen yeah just put in the little
corner like all right imagine if you
could like i think it's stupid that the
olympics don't let people like stream it
yeah imagine if you had like twitch chat
with the olympics i think that would be
awesome i think we've said this before
on trash taste but like that's why like
i really really wanted all this stuff on
on the screen yeah the cycling things
i'm like cycling is like inherently
you know it's not that you know it's not
that exciting yeah like it's just not
like if i was just cycling pov across
japan it's like right
cool yeah nice like walking the same
it's like give me something like give me
yeah give me some stuff to get invested
true gamer you're just
you're turning irl into a game well
that's kind of what i wanted it to be
like i kind of wanted it to be where
anyone could hop in and kind of get a
feel for what where we're at yeah you
have to ask oh how far in are we it's
like
we're 80 of the way there yeah oh uh
we're we're eating lunch and we're 47 of
the way there oh the days you started
with five you know what i mean like yeah
a lot of the questions people are going
to ask uh in the chat and stuff like
that just get that out of the way
there's never any questions about how
we're doing how's it you know it's like
you can everything is visually explained
and and it doesn't impose i think it
adds to it because it's not like there's
much i need to show yeah literally just
uh yeah me gay and like i i had like a
a fail proof for like everything um
except a spare bike which i nearly broke
of course you do of course like my brand
every new bike
i was smart though i got insurance on my
bike okay that's good that's good that's
good that's good we learned from
ourselves the insurance was like
it was like
percent of the bikes [ __ ] cost but it
covered everything it was like if the
bike literally come bust or get stolen
yeah yeah they'll replace it it's monkey
proof yeah literally like no matter what
i do to it it is
they'll they'll no questions asked yeah
yeah yeah and it's great for me because
if i was live streaming i broke it i'm
like
it's proof
right here bro
oh yeah i nearly broke it on the second
day it's not good
was that when you fell over or yeah yeah
i was pointing to something in the
distance holding on with my left hand
and i went over a big rock right thing
like wobbled yeah and i just went right
into the yeah the pavement and it was a
really big like it's not maybe like this
big of sidewalk from the road
pavement for british people um and i
just like jumped into the bush i didn't
want to land on the sidewalk oh yeah i
was like that's just gonna hurt yeah but
i didn't also want my bike to get
wrecked so i i just didn't in the second
i was like i just can't decide i'll just
jump
but i i was also excited
my first time ever using them i had the
clip in yeah yeah yeah which are awesome
by the way it makes cycling like way
easier and also you have to think less
you have to worry where your legs are
you just
yeah like a like a steam engine just
keep you just keep pushing you don't
like the machine yeah i mean like i'm
sure to work with chris is on but he's
just like slipping and [ __ ] yeah yeah
like it's just it's good but also it's
bad for situations like that yeah but
luckily uh if you jump hard enough
you'll get out of the clips
and i think i did and they've made a
good clip it was completely by accident
and luckily there's no cars on the road
right at that point uh i mean we're in
the middle of nowhere yeah yeah but yeah
it was it was you have to be pretty
unlucky to get hit by a car
on a road that's practically empty that
would be tough that would be tough i
mean there was that that was an aspect
that was really
uh you get used to pretty fast but it
was very anxious the first time where
you cycle on the road oh yeah
and tunnels especially yeah tunnels of
the sky used to it tunnels is terrifying
cause the echo in a tunnel when you're
cycling in it is terrifying right right
because the car comes in or here in the
background
like fifteen thousand echoes coming
right that's terrifying you and you know
it's coming from behind you and you're
like oh no oh no please please don't
don't hear me don't you please please
i don't have your lights on yeah he's
like please see me please see me please
and you're literally just hoping you
just don't die yeah that's it
hoping it's not like because i saw like
the one one of the clips where that
massive truck yeah almost clipped you or
that was that was unnecessarily scary
because it was literally a
a country road with so much room and no
one no one was on these roads yeah and
he went so close to me and i thought why
why just being addicted like
it was enough room
probably in europe it's probably the
normal amount of room yeah but i was
just like come on man it wasn't like it
was like a busy road like i don't know
that that was probably not as close as
some other ones but other times we were
on a road and i chose to be on the road
because
when you're cycling for ages going on
the the pavement the sidewalk it's bumpy
and up and down and [ __ ] paved and it's
just not good and after a while you're
just like i just want a cycle i do not
want to have to think or get my ass hurt
or stop or slow down you just want to
keep you just want to have the exercise
bike experience yeah
right and you go so much faster on the
road yeah and it's like whatever i don't
give a [ __ ] about the cars even when i'm
driving i don't give a [ __ ] if i have to
just like wait a second to get around
the cyclist it's a road bike let me go
on the road yeah also my favorite part
is when i saw other japanese cyclists
and we just nodded each other that was
fun
the mutual you
now every other cyclist that was like
also wearing serious gear would not
always
it was like a mutual respect you'd wave
especially when like i don't know like
you uh you were coming down like
you were going up a big hill and after
yeah yeah they knew and you're like oh
no he's like oh he ain't normally
one of us
yeah just like one night we had to drive
back um
[Music]
we did drive down the biggest incline we
did right and in the car we were like
this is stupid i can't believe we cycled
up this yeah it's like ten we're like on
this road for like 10 minutes driving
down we're like this we cycled up this
this is insane yeah because like day one
the first incline we're like oh dying
we're like we can't do this this is too
much and by like day seven you're just
like all right let's get used to all
right 5k incline let's do it let's just
go you just get used to it it's like
it's like it's just a different
sensation you don't like it doesn't hurt
nearly as much yeah just kind of like
it just uses a different part of you
it's really interesting i i
i really want to keep cycling more i
feel really fit
yeah
i mean
if you don't feel fit after this i don't
know what's going on
because like your heart rate is like
literally
it's just elevated all day long like
you're just purely exercising like
seven eight hours a day yeah that's it
for eight days no breaks it's probably
terrible if you actually want to build
muscle and actually do it healthfully uh
but yeah it's great to lose body fat if
you want to lose weight it's great but i
wouldn't recommend it it's just like
it's i mean it's pretty like yeah it's
it's like not eating for three days yeah
it's awful because like you know you're
burning like i don't know i think most
days you were burning like five four
thousand calories a day
so it's like oh it's on top of your
daily like 2 000 yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you're just like there's no possible way
you can eat 8 000 calories a day
like unless you're like actually trying
your hardest yeah yeah yeah i just
didn't want to eat i don't stop cycling
i don't want to [ __ ] eat yeah it's i
mean like it's i mean i think it's a
great way to lose weight if you want to
like [ __ ]
do that i mean i don't think i lost that
much weight because i was also i was
drinking a lot of beer
well that made the beer worth it though
right that was that's the sweet that's
how you're putting back the 8 000
calories just like like 10 pints of beer
yeah well i i mean i ate i ate as much
as i could
at every point but yeah there's even
then it's like you just
i don't know if if only we had our
health check up right now right corner i
know yeah
that was the real ingredient i was just
like [ __ ] my health jacob's coming up
i'm going to drop some weight
like it's like you you finish it like
five
six pm every day and then you've got a
shower yeah yeah yeah and then i have to
charge everything so i have to charge
the
like uh the giant portable bat portable
battery have to charge all the router uh
router which is a british one
i call it router i don't know which one
it is it's it's pretty rude i say router
i i've heard i don't say i don't think
people say router so maybe it's
the american one i have to charge all of
you i feel like i feel like ruto is like
the southern maybe yeah maybe
this episode is sponsored by hongkai
impact third hong kong impact third
tells the story of the valkyries
fighting against an energy called honkai
that erodes the world and protects
humanity and guess what for
mid-september honker impact third
version 6.0 will officially begin
okay okay we got new characters we got a
second phase of the summer event and a
major update for the main chapter as
well we have gentlemen a brand new
battle suit alicia as the herscher of
human ego after unleashing her ultimate
alicia marks off an area then transforms
into a mermaid floating free and happy
in an ocean of stars and guys right now
they are doing a summer event you know
how it is guys you know how it is we are
getting part two of the summer event
storyline and guys guys listen to me
this event includes three new chapters
and you have a chance to get some more
nice outfits guys come on it's summer
come on celebrate guys celebrate tell
you but gentlemen wait there's more
there's more download the game now to
redeem the gift code on screen and get
30 crystals what 2
88 asteroids and a hershey trial card
for free click the link in the
description below
thank you to honkai for sponsoring this
video back to the show i i have to like
charge my my phone my stream phone uh
the two portable batteries in my bike
the uh the giant battery uh the
three routers um
everything else and then i have to put
it all back in the bike and it's just
it's a lot every day yeah yeah you
pretty much didn't get to do anything
for like eight days well i mean like was
there anywhere you'd want to go back to
and oh yeah like nobody bet 2 was cool
oh no
it's a really famous onsen town yeah ah
and that was really cool
because a lot of the towns you went to
just had nothing
just nothing in there yeah i think it
was three days we didn't see anything
yeah i feel like anything north of like
sub-par is pretty much just like i know
i was really sick oh other than our
psychologist
i was very small like there were some
places that only had
like one hotel within like a uh you know
like a 80 kilometer radius yeah yeah
yeah like um
uh i'm sure
chris can tell the story about this
racist hotel staff but there's already
clips of it and stuff not racist i don't
know [ __ ] or maybe just a horrible
person
[Music]
that's the difficulty being in traffic
especially in like the country in japan
are you being racist or are you just
like oh
but like there was like you know uh the
first night there was like no hotels in
this area just none right it was just
only like one hostel
and it just like didn't make sense for
us to go in hostel when we had to charge
charge everything yeah yeah it'd be up
so early and we were going to get there
so late and stuff so it was just it was
just tough
really tough i don't know
how you would would you would you do it
again
like some something like that cycle not
hokkaido again right hokkaido is way
harder than anywhere else in japan
somewhere a little more like with a
little more civilization i'd love to do
it uh i mean crystal's also chris
already already was like maybe we should
do another one sometime soon
i mean i don't mind
yeah i i the idea was like maybe kyushu
or something right that makes more sense
right because it's the whole island yeah
yeah it's a lot hillier though yeah but
then apparently chris was telling me
there's a there's another way this is
like the west or east side that's not as
hilly or whatever i don't mind same
famous last words yeah it's like i'm
fine i know a way i know i'm with hills
it was like way more successful than i
thought yeah i thought it wasn't gonna
be i thought the viewership on my twitch
was not gonna be as good as it was yeah
um i thought cause it was like i thought
i wouldn't like watch it if i
just watched someone cycle i don't know
i mean i feel like irl content on twitch
she's just doing really really well
right now definitely
uh because no one else can come to japan
that's why so that's the only that's
literally the only way that people would
just create their knees it's great you
can just show off a [ __ ] combination
like
chat think irl stuff should always be
like an event not i don't know how you
could be uh like i don't know how rob
does it uh robert i don't know how rob
does he streams like five days a week
yeah
i don't know how those like how have you
not run out of places to go
yeah i don't know how he does it i i
would be
sick of going outside yeah i would just
touching too much
i'm like can i can i not touch grass
i think it's great to have irl stream
events i think as one-offs they're
really good and i think twitch right now
or streaming in general like irl is a
really big uh like trend right yeah yeah
there's always been a thing but i think
right now it's particularly popular than
anything yeah definitely um when it's
done well yeah so if you want to try it
try it it just sucks because the barrier
of entry to irl streaming is
very very high well yeah um also cycling
as well
on top of it if you want to get into
like the amount of cycling that you did
to
like you don't need to buy all the [ __ ]
that i bought like you could get a [ __ ]
bike and do the same thing it would just
be harder oh yeah like this bike wasn't
would you have a good time though doing
your bra
this bike was my bike was nutty i've
never had gears that changed like that
like i've never had a bike where you
just tap it
boom change gear
immediately no questions asked the bike
is like bra i got you doesn't matter
what hell you're on anything boom tap it
you want to go two hold it down twice as
long it's insane i've never had
something
so now that you've had the cycling
experience what do you think makes a
good bike
what would you recommend now that you're
a cycling expert
now that you're uh you know that you're
the traveler
like this bike and this bike was nuts
like i i don't understand how people can
like review bikes for a living i'm just
like what are you what are you looking
for like i feel like every bike is
slightly i feel like you can say that
with any niche though yeah
i wanted a bike that was good for the
lazy man because mine had a thing so you
got you you got the apple of bikes
kinda i kind of got like the like yeah
like the full so i bought my bike purely
on the reason that
it had um the headlights and the rear
light like built into the bike right and
then you just charge this battery pack
on the the frame and then it's just
controlled by an app no you just turn
the lights on or if it gets dark they
automatically turn on
easy and i was like cool that sounds
good because i hate turning on these
lights i always forget to send them off
and i just i'm i understand that this is
such a lazy reason to get it but i just
wanted to do it turns out it became a
pain at one point because when i had no
internet i couldn't turn my lights on
oh
there's no there's no way to turn them
and on really felt like that moment
where boomers are like
why do you why are you gonna put
technology and everything we did we we
had lights that work just fine without
these [ __ ] apps
why do you need smart
truly felt at balls point where it was
like ah
this sucks this is so dumb why does that
why is there not a way for this this is
an oversight
there's no way for me to turn it on
without the app yeah this is [ __ ]
dumb yeah when when the when the
inevitable rogue ai you know
starts taking over humanity yeah we're
gonna look back at this point and be
like why can't we turn on the lights
without our [ __ ] smart tap so you're
gonna pay like 10 10 bezos bucks today
play a subscription service yeah
i did i i i oh my god so i bought this
bike so i said four thousand dollars but
i think it's normally four thousand
dollars i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but yeah um i went to the store
and i because i already knew what bike i
wanted
and they had it in the store because i i
i didn't understand how how you buy
bikes really i just thought although
i'll just have the bike in the store
yeah turns out like
like if the store's small they don't
have your bike they have to order it for
you which can take months yeah so i was
like chris i was like you by the way you
can't just like wait you should go now
yeah yeah so he waited like two weeks
before and couldn't get the same bike as
me but he wanted the same bike as me
right um so he couldn't get that one
because he
he the store he had didn't have it but
luckily i went to the store and they had
it i had it in like shining purple and i
was like oh [ __ ] sick yeah trash
tastes represent
yeah got it
and um yeah it was really weird it was
like
um three thousand dollars and for some
reason the day that i went to the store
they had a campaign on was like yeah you
get
uh ten percent off uh the bike just pick
any bike just because
and then i got extra money off because i
paid in cash and it ended up costing
like 2 500 bucks and i was like oh okay
okay cool not too bad then um i was like
sweet i've got these apps and stuff is
that is that not too bad that's 500 off
i mean i paid for the insurance
it is an amazing bike it is it's a
beautiful non-cyclist be like
carbon fiber a beautiful specimen i'm
like damn like and the first bike i
bought was like 150 dollars like that's
[ __ ] expensive
this bike it was god tier dude it was
like perfect yeah you do not need a good
badge of this i definitely like just
just because i had the money i just
splurged yeah that's purely like a you
do not need this kind of bike right um
so yeah and then i bought the bike and i
started sweating when i when i went to
the app store to download the app and i
saw the reviews and i had 2.1 stars and
i was like
it's not going to work
yeah and i've been trying to update my
sensor in the bike for like a month now
can't update it just doesn't work just
doesn't let me update it
can't update my bike the lights
they turn on but they're so finicky
right it's so annoying i'm just like i
for [ __ ] sake why would they not just
put a button to turn it on
like this isn't expensive
we're going real minimalistic with our
design an expensive bike and this the
lights are a pain in the [ __ ] ass to
turn on yeah they put all these like
bits and bobs on a bike but they were
like switch for the light switch no no
we don't need a switch i also like you
know i might the seat on the bike you
know i assume if i'm the super most
serious cyclist on earth it's great
it's just not comfortable it is tiny
it's tiny is there air is there does is
there any bike that actually has a
comfortable seat for road bikes
generally they're not yeah they're not
they're like really small and they're
meant to you know because
cyclists are like all right get used to
it that's kind of what it is you just
have to you literally just have to
destroy your ass yeah yeah yeah
and i was like can i change the seats we
you know i take the seat off and i'm
like oh
yeah the the rear headlight that is
hardwired to the bike cannot be removed
from this
seat so i have no choice but to use the
seat right that's how they rope you into
it
so i have to buy like this padded suit
but i really wanted this bike right
because it was perfect for what i wanted
it was like an endurance bike and the
wheels were a bit thicker than normal
road bikes and it was it was good god he
did buy the apple of bikes he did
[ __ ] no accessories no customization
yeah everything is included yeah yeah i
imagine like trying to fix this bike is
a pain
um
like that particular comfortable you
break the warranty you have to have like
specialist equipment i
two year warranty cost me 600 [ __ ]
dollars to for insurance and [ __ ] on
this bike
i had to
register with the police as you do in
japan oh yeah yeah yeah
because it's like it's like it's
considered a vehicle registration in
japan yeah yeah and
yeah that's why getting rid of a bike as
well is [ __ ] pain in the air
i want to get rid of this you can't just
like yeah but if you if you were to for
whatever reason it's the biggest pain in
the ass i remember when i got rid of my
bike it was like a whole like
like three week process just like call
them up and be like i want to get rid of
this bike and then you have to do all
this paperwork to like unregister the
bike and then you have to get rid of the
bike which costs you know well luckily i
think this bike's nice enough where i
could probably just sell it oh yeah i
don't think i will i mean i love this
bike this bike's awesome yeah i really
want to
you know eventually cycle around like
europe or something
well now that you've invested this much
money into it it would be a shame if you
didn't use it again i mean i you know
i've been cycling to the before this i
was cycling to the studio a lot and i
loved it i think it's dude
after cycling on this bike it's like oh
this is like
how cycling is supposed to feel
like
cycling in the shin amikaido and cycling
right you're doing these uphills it
feels like the bike is just like not
doing anything yeah yeah
square wheels it's just like you pedal
and it feels like nothing's happening
well that's that's why
a lot of the times we just ended up
walking up the hills yeah because it
felt like less effort you know i think i
was actually moving
faster because like the energy the
energy you're putting into each pedal
like wasn't translating is like yeah
what you kind of wanted yeah whereas
like with this bike like it was just
like every like rotation you put into it
felt like it went
directly into pushing you because it's
such a nice bike and it's so good and it
was crazy like up hills man i've never
had anything like that it felt like
you're slowly walking up a hill right
because the on the lowest lowest gear it
was basically like walking up a hill
it's crazy it's such a good bike we're
this is this is now the connor cyclist
arc we have now entered everyone
i just can't believe that i thought the
shin namicato was hard like that's
that's like maybe maybe we just nerfed
ourselves we should do it again and then
i'll just be like all right guys boys i
finished three hours
[Music]
this bike is nutty i just it's i didn't
realize how
good these road bikes obviously if
you're a better cyclist you'll you'll
still like you know you'll be able to
use it more of course like i never did
the
just because i couldn't be bothered um
because it was just pain in the ass you
know where you can go right on the
bottom handlebars and be more wind yes
resistant i never wanted to go that fast
and i know so it was horrible for the
camera angle yeah so i'll just be
pointing at the ground so i never ever
did that
um so i wasn't really using the bike for
it's like full potential if you will i'm
sure cyclists are like cringy potential
you know what i mean because like it's
super saiyan body
like the weather conditions bro i i
thought rain was the worst turns out no
wind is the worst all right wind wind is
number one can [ __ ] off when you're
playing well that's literally why like
professional cyclists in the olympics
they have like
they literally have a [ __ ] team you
know it's it's it's
uh the
wind is like
it can make downhills feel like flats if
it's strong enough
and it's crazy you'll be going on the
flat and you'll be you you'll have to
put the same amount of energy as going
up a hill just to keep going yeah
because the wind will be so crazy i it's
i just was like [ __ ] this like if if
this was this every day i would i
couldn't do it yeah
we got so lucky that one or two days
were perfect we had rain some days which
is miserable because your feet get like
trench foot yeah and you're just soaked
it's just should have had someone just
like tank the wind for you like a like
an olympics i was following chris a lot
of the time because
he he did a good job with that yeah he
did it because chris i don't know why
it was good i mean when there was like
certain days where i
felt like i could just keep cycling till
the end of time right we did like 120k
one day which is the longest day and at
the end of it i just felt like yeah i
could do another 50 another 60. i felt
totally like good to go nice i don't
know why some days you just feel it and
other days you're like holy [ __ ] 10k is
so hard yeah um i don't know it's i feel
like that's true with exercise in
general though you know yeah it sucks
because when you do something like this
those days where you would normally wake
up and be like no how how i would do
exercise today yeah yeah
it's not gonna happen because you you
know those days where you when you turn
to the gym and you just you just you're
just [ __ ] yes everything the walk to the
gym you're just like oh you're you're
leaving you know you know this day is
gonna suck yeah start running on the
treadmill after two minutes you're like
[ __ ] i can't yeah you you can't even do
your like normal reps like everything's
[ __ ] it's just like that but like in
cycling form and you're like
like i wouldn't even be tired but my
muscles like my leg muscles would be
just so [ __ ] that i just couldn't get
them to pedal the speed i wanted them to
go to right whereas other days it would
be just easy like i could just maintain
like a crazy pace all day don't know why
and yeah it was it was awesome like it
just kind of depended on a lot of
factors i don't know why like i i'm like
some days i would like like the day
after sapporo i had drank in sapporo so
much beer like i had like six or seven
pints of beer
because i was like i'm in sapporo baby i
gotta
and then that was like my best cycling
day the day after i just i'd killed it
like i just i was on fire fueled by
sapporo class really clearly like either
like the the sapporo beer has got
something in it right like i
i was a machine i drank every day
that's probably why you didn't
yeah probably i mean it's because every
day i had like two beers after it's all
right i don't have a beer
you want it
that was rough yeah that empowered me
yeah and yeah i was good but uh yeah i
definitely recommend uh doing something
crazy congratulations you want to do it
you want to do it
i don't know i mean i want to do
something crazy yeah i mean i think
we've
it's it's weird because this year has
just been a crazy crazy year just in
general we've already done some pretty
good crazy things it's not even [ __ ]
over yet i'm gonna do it next time you
wanna i'll be down oh no like did you
actually i would actually be down like
six seven days yeah i guess because you
you've got you've got me to tell you all
the everything they're doing yeah right
i've done i've found out how to exactly
everything exactly
yeah no but like i i mean you know if i
want to [ __ ] get because you know i
do want to get into shape um and so you
know why
would i you know what what better excuse
than to do for you know a charity or an
event i don't think it's a good way to
get like
super fit there's like way better ways
to do it yeah but you just want to get a
kick start yeah i think it's well like
you know it's just to say that you did
it as well oh yeah it's a cool [ __ ]
story to tell it's cool yeah but i feel
like it's especially if you want to get
fit you know it's i'm sure like there's
so many better there are better ways of
course there are better ways to min max
it but at the end of the day if you're
not having fun or if you're not doing
this you don't have to know
the motivation there's going to be more
efficient ways to do it yes but if you
don't want to do it you're not going to
do it you know it's kind of it's kind of
like it's it's very similar to i guess
learning a language and everything like
that is like what i've realized is that
there is always a more efficient way to
learn japanese or learn another language
but at the end of the day the most
important thing is
having fun
no joke no jokes it [ __ ] is okay look
if like we've like clowned on duolingo
so much but if you if duolingo gets you
up and gets you doing a language
exercise every day that's way [ __ ]
better than other methods that are way
more efficient absolutely um yeah i mean
sometimes the stars align right and yeah
everything just kind of works out yeah
and uh you
set a challenge
and it kind of just hits every box you
want yeah you know like for me it was
started out as me just wanted to do
something stupid yeah and then i was
like oh i get personal fitness i get to
make some content i get to cycle with my
friends and then i get to also raise
money for a great cause and yeah
hopefully i get to entertain a bunch of
people throughout it so i think you know
you sometimes you just
you know you're like this is gonna be
tough this is not gonna be easy and it's
gonna it's gonna be a nuisance to my
life because you know like i couldn't
really do much after the day was over
yeah people would text me but i would
just i couldn't [ __ ] reply i was just
so i was too tired i wouldn't look at my
phone yeah i literally ate
changed clothes showered put stuff on
charge went to bed then woke up at six
five a.m every day yeah it was tough and
then today i had to wake up at 5am to
get the shinkansen from hakodate to get
here to film the base
i literally finished it yesterday yeah
yeah it's crazy to think i was in
hokkaido yesterday yeah and you just got
the shoe you wanted you're in the code
this morning yeah yeah yeah this morning
this morning oh man yeah it's it's uh
yeah and like the number one tip to
cycling long distances is just wake up
early but
i'm sure when chris comes on he'll tell
you all about it we had so many
arguments about what time to wake up
right we actually we like had on like
four years because yeah because chris is
like the number one like i hate waking
up in the morning post we had like a
shouting match at one point about this
in like a restaurant we were we were
this is like five we are so stressed out
right because you're cycling all day
you're pissed off yeah and and i was
getting i was getting really pissed off
for chris was
under the bridge afterwards like but we
were like so pissed off what time did he
want to wake up
he you know because he was arguing that
like uh if i wake up too early i'm i'm
you know i won't get enough sleep and i
won't be in condition to do anything and
i'm like
just get over it just like
because just get good
just don't be tired don't be tired i'm
sure you can talk about it
because we've done video shoots together
right yeah and sometimes you do shoots
with a lot of people yeah sometimes
for the for the the greater good of the
shoot you just have to sacrifice things
yeah and i think chris cause chris
normally controls everything on his
videos yes he controls it so that he
doesn't have to wake up early right yeah
but for this it was like we're just not
gonna hit
the places because i i i was like
insistent on the fact that
i did not want to cycle in the dark yeah
i just thought that oh it looks like
[ __ ] first it looks like [ __ ] and also
it's just unnecessarily adding like a
dangerous elements to it for no reason
like
yeah you have lights on your bike but
you can't see stuff as well you can't
see the the rocks and the roads these
roads are [ __ ] yeah you can't see the
potholes you can't see the cut the cars
can't see you as well like i just i just
thought that it's you're just adding
unnecessary danger for no reason yeah
and we could just wake up an hour early
yeah you know because originally we're
waking up at like we were starting at
like 9 30. and i just thought that's way
too late yeah that's surprisingly late
and so we eventually got it down to like
8 8 30 after arguing a bunch and like ah
because i was on the other crazy
spectrum where i was like listen if i
have to get six hours of sleep five
hours of sleep for a week of my life so
be it like it's it's it's a week of my
life i'll get over it i'll recover i'll
just sleep extra yeah like obviously
it's not ideal but you just make
sacrifices to make stuff happen yes
uh but christian's like this
content yeah but you know it was i i
understand where he's coming from i know
you know i'm younger and i can it's way
easier for me to i mean you're not that
much young
i don't know like
six years younger i don't know like for
me i waking up and losing a bit of like
for me five hours of sleep that's not a
big issue if it's like it's a big issue
i'm i'm i'm saying if if okay if we were
doing this and i was like gone you have
to get five hours of sleep and we're
doing it you wouldn't be happy about it
but you'd probably be like all right
yeah okay so like i think the difference
between being 30 is that you just know
what your body is capable of right you
know you know some days where you think
okay okay okay so yeah i'd say like i
understood where he's coming from i
wasn't trying to be a dick about it i'm
not even 30 and i can already feel that
no that's that's because you're almost
30 joey that's almost
that's i think that's the big tester
where you've limit tested your body
enough to know what the limits are right
so i can do like five hours of sleep
yeah and six thousand sleep but i know i
know if i do five to six hours of sleep
i'm gonna have a write-off day it's
there's there's yes
it's law of equal exchange i'm going
like the price is going to catch up to
your body yeah and if i have a five hour
night the next night is a 12 hour yeah
yeah exactly exactly i understand that i
that sleep was definitely a necessity
yeah um
my solution was just go to bed earlier
because chris was going to bed like
midnight i was going to bed like 10.
yeah because i think chris got really
unlucky a bunch of stuff i mean he'll
talk about it a bunch of stuff piled on
yeah emails and important things he had
to do so he wasn't sleeping properly
which is also like
you know it was i i just told everyone
i'm like don't don't bother don't you
don't talk to me i'm not going to reply
to anyone yes because i'm just like i
just i just don't want to worry about
anything i just want to turn off i told
the agency i was like hey
just you can you can ask me do it do
what you want but i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna reply unless it's like gigger
urgent yeah um so yeah i went to bed
every night like ten so waking up at six
is like oh that's nothing yeah that's
plenty yeah my mindset was we just go to
bed
eight hours of sleep yeah because a lot
of the times we all said bye and we're
like we would all have dinner and talk a
bit then we'd all go to bed like we'd
all head off at nine yeah so i was like
just go to bed you know yeah easy worst
case you don't get seven hours of sleep
which is fine seven hours of sleep is
also in the recommended amount that's
still pretty good you know yeah um so
that's what i always think but then
obviously you know
everyone sleeps different as well yeah
is it um is that an old man thing now to
really value your sleep i value my sleep
don't get me wrong i i normally i i am
hard on the seven eight hours necessary
yeah but i i when it comes to like a an
outdoor shoot where we've all traveled
and a lot of people and money and time
has invested i'm completely of the
mindset of like
if i get two hours i get two hours
that's what it is no because like i've i
remember actually for for the drifting
special yeah yeah actually was no sleep
for that like the road trip we got like
no sleep yeah
the road trip was like five years
like
i stayed in the hotel that we stayed in
in hakodate right i remember i was like
oh yeah the last time i was here
we literally were there for four hours
yeah yeah we booked a hotel room just to
sleep for four hours we got to that
hotel at i think it was like 12 00 a.m
no it was like one or two a.m
and then we had to wake up at i think
six inches yeah yeah yeah yeah we
literally booked a hotel yeah for just
like four hours yeah
yeah we just did that because there was
a video shoot and we understood that
like to make these things happen we had
to sacrifice sleep exactly obviously
it's a different i understand it's
completely different when you when it
comes to the fact that i'm like okay
sacrifice sleep now exercise for eight
hours yes yes that's so i i
i i was content we were all content yeah
it was we were both tired it's been five
days cycling we were pissed off but it
was you know we we understood that like
immediately after you're like that's 400
bridges yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
me and chris piss each other off all the
time
chris is just like eighty percent of
chris is just angry at all times anyway
well you know uh well not angry
of shoots yes i was like this is both of
our shoots so
you can't just be like this is what
we're doing yeah i'm like no i'm pushing
back hard on it
i'm gonna be the i'm gonna be the one
who pushes back
uh you know because i
we we were slowly getting later and
later and i was like if we start at 10
we're [ __ ] yeah we're not gonna make
it because also okay so to to preface
how all this works it was eight days and
it was like 95 kilometers 90 85 85. and
we were just about finishing before
sunset when we were doing 95 and 80. um
because we were we were slow we were
taking our time we were stopping for
lunch and we're doing stuff like that
and um originally the last day was gonna
be 160.
damn and as we were getting closer to
that day this is when i was like dude
we're gonna have to wake up at like 4
a.m yeah and like i'm i just it's one
day i'm chill to do it and we were like
having arguments and stuff about it
because i'm not waking up before i am
because yeah i'm not gonna be able to do
it i was like alright fine so we
eventually came to the conclusion that
we had to like
somehow spread out the distance in the
remaining days so instead of doing like
80 100 160 we did 120 110 110 right um
and that was tough because then that
turned what was going to be two normal
days and a really hard day into like
just three hard days right right um
which was tough that was tough
it's hard that was tough
that was hard but you know you get used
to it i don't know it's hard but it was
really fun you sound like you know you
know when like marines go through their
like their training where they like run
[ __ ] like 100 kilometers or something
a day i think you're just like you know
you just got to learn to push past
yourself
it's weird it's like yeah when they're
like it was tough i'm like
it's not the word you would describe you
subscribe
it's weird how quickly your body can
adapt to things oh of course i mean you
if you have like you you know like
we had like hard deadlines right like
you had to do this distance in the day
yeah so it's kind of like
you gotta do it i mean your body and
your mind is just incredibly flexible to
a point yeah yeah you know you're
capable of way more than you think you
are oh yeah well i mean i mean like
remember like the the crazy schedule
that we had for like la miami and then
australia in the span of like a week and
a half like when we were looking at that
before it was happening we were like
there's no [ __ ] where we're gonna be
but by the end of it we were like okay
yeah that was tough but
i mean we still did it
anything can be handled i never met prep
literally it's just all prep if you just
prep properly for this this kind of
stuff it's so easy yeah yeah definitely
you know and it's really amazing how um
fast and how many days your body will
kind of like even like by day four like
i said like hills became way easier like
i had not had any really really tough
hills before i've been doing a lot of it
on on tokyo which is really flat tokyo
doesn't have that many hills um and also
like the exercise bike you can put the
resistance up but it's not the same yes
the resistance the resistance cannot
mimic going up a hill no it's just
totally different because you don't feel
like you're going to fall off
you never feel like you're going to fall
off the resistance right it's just going
to push back whereas the hill it's like
if you don't like cycle properly you
just fall off your bike yeah um and you
you know changing gear it's a whole
thing and uh you know it's it's
impressive how even after like three
days it becomes so much easier if you
just keep going yeah um and you get like
rapid improvement if you do it every day
yeah kind of i guess like learning
like language right like anything like
anything like if you wanted to get your
muscles to be like to actually get like
healthy and grow the muscles properly
then you take rest days yeah and i was
definitely not eating enough protein i
just don't know how i could eat that
much protein
liquid protein i truly who needs protein
when you've got carbs i've tried to eat
protein but it's hard enough to eat like
calories let alone like yeah the protein
i should have taken protein powder with
me or something yeah but i just i just
couldn't just snort probably so much
there's always so much stuff yeah yeah i
should have liked
all
right yeah
yeah it's just like you you put on all
of that and then you've got to worry
about the stream yeah and it's just like
another added layer of like [ __ ] yeah so
you're like mentally tied you're
physically tired yeah
man yeah well congratulations for
actually achieving it i can achieve and
write this one thank you crazy looking
forward to seeing chris's video and your
like edited down video as well meanwhile
i was sitting on my fat ass playing
xenoblade 3.
i felt kind of felt bad when i saw that
i woke up every day i saw connor doing
this and i'm like yeah i'm going to
stream genji today
it's just like yeah stream gets you for
seven hours
i'm worse i didn't listen i'm worth i'm
worse than you at least you were like
yeah i might you know also stream you
know i i wasn't even like i wasn't even
like you know what i might even stream i
was just like no i'm not even gonna
stream i'm just gonna
sit back and just enjoy myself it's just
me i just like doing like crazy
things that push the the envelope with
you i don't know what is that the first
thing yeah yeah definitely why why does
it push the envelope what the [ __ ] i
don't know
i don't know english like i don't know
like i wanted to do something crazy on
twitch yeah i have like a big event and
i wanted to do something that was like
you know that hadn't really been seen a
lot on twitch i don't know i've done it
before but i wanted to do it in like a
way that was really unique gamified yeah
yeah i just i just wanted to make it
hype and um
i like pushing the boundaries of what
you can do on live streams and i think
his stuff was like interesting i don't
know i'm like addicted to making stuff i
guess
you're just you're addicted to content
yeah i think i think we're all addicted
to content in one way shape or form
i love playing games but i'm like man
you know nobody in my head i'm like man
nobody nobody remembers that guy who
just [ __ ] played games unless you're
a markiplier you know what i mean
to be honest if i feel like if you're
not addicted like if we weren't addicted
to content i don't think we would have
lasted this long
yeah cause like that's at the end of the
day that's what it is like the people
who last longer than not are the ones
who are like constantly just trying to
push themselves to do
bigger and better things people always
ask like um you know if worry that if
we're gonna get burnt out or i'm gonna
burn out i'm just like well no i kind of
get like sad when i'm not making stuff i
really feel fulfilled and happy when i'm
making stuff it's good stuff and it's
rewarding i i get burnt out if i just
make stuff i always need a constant this
is the next big projects that you are
going to be doing and working towards
and i notice i think that's the one
thing we all have in common where i know
what my big my next big project is and
i'm sure like you guys like we're we're
constantly planning different things
both together and now individually as
well yeah so it's it's it's it's weird
and i guess that's like
it's it's great actually having you guys
as friends because i see you doing this
i'm like [ __ ] now i got to get on my ass
and do something exciting and do yeah
and and do something and do something it
is it's just like it's just like
constantly having the next goal yeah to
reach and then once you've reached that
goal yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
once you've reached that goal then
there's that new goal and then there's a
new goal and you go and just keeps on
cycling but like the bros just keep you
on your toes you know yeah
it does it's like being spotted you know
he's just like come on come on you can
benches
one more one more one more you got this
you got this i'm obsessed with the idea
of doing like some kayaking stream i
really want to do a kayaking show for
kayaking yeah i just but
do you know what's the one thing though
that you really have to be careful of
the kayaking stream if you fall off the
kayak oh yeah yeah it's ripperone's yeah
like
yeah yeah your stream is [ __ ] yeah at
least with alice at least you're on land
on a bicycle there
there like i i was thinking about how
you could maybe have so like i had to
because obviously when it was raining
yeah i had to kind of have something
waterproof yeah uh it was like it worked
but obviously it won't work if you
submerge it yeah it's splash proof but i
i know that some people make these
plastic housings for the stuff i
wondered if you could make it kind of
well i mean there's those like plastic
housings for like uh big cameras you
know underwater
come out of it kind of somehow exactly
yeah so that would have to be the whole
thing basically
as well yeah but the wire length would
have that that seems like a technique a
lot of challenges but uh yeah you
probably need to be 3d printed or some
[ __ ] like that probably probably but it
could be i would want to do a kayaking
stream kind of like maybe the same deal
you do that distance i think you're
pretty hype sure just kayaking all day
yeah same the honest thing is that it
would be super [ __ ] boring kayaking
if you unless you had like a really sick
lake
you would need to have like a really
interesting route yeah i feel like yeah
yeah yeah but dude kayaking i think he's
fun as [ __ ] though it's awesome but i
know that like your feet get [ __ ]
after a while because you're just being
like in the wet kayaking after a while
yeah
yeah also just yeah
yeah maybe like a day thing i could do
it uh it could be pretty high i i kind
of want to figure out how to do it um um
maybe someday i'll figure out yeah i try
to do more interesting irl stuff like i
had a
i had a a theory that you could set it
up this way and i never ended up doing
it just because i was so tired every day
i had so the way that the backpack works
you can put like a mic into the back of
the camera
and you put a lap mic so i had this big
brain idea i was like wait
my cable's long enough where if you put
the bag in the back of the car and then
put a suction cup on the back of the car
with a camera mount you could feed the
camera that's in the bags in the car you
could feed the camera with the wire onto
the suction cup behind you you're you're
wearing a lav mic and then you could be
have the car trail you
really oh
like a third person camera and then you
could have literally like a like a third
person view of you with the mic on you
and it would be streaming how sick would
that look
i thought man that would be so cool to
do that'd be like that'd be like if you
had your regular streaming setup but it
was moving yeah kind of yeah it's
literally like marching like the problem
is that like you'd have to do it in a
place like if we would have done it we
would have done it on the first few days
you'd need like a road that was empty
yeah to try it well so i actually want
to [ __ ] around and set it all up it was
such a big hassle yeah maybe if i
prepared more i could have done it but
it was a lot of crap but i thought it'd
be a sick idea
or you've got something for next time
yeah i could try it next time if i have
more time if we have like a day where we
don't have as much going on yeah but
like a lot of the time google maps
wouldn't send you down the right route
yeah probably not google that's so
annoying that just didn't well like
okay so here's the thing google maps
works perfectly i find in the city but
you go to a country that might not be as
well developed or go to an area that is
you know not as you know a bit more
rural you know out and out of the city
and google maps does not work as
efficiently as you think it does at all
it would just like especially when you
fix the cycling option yeah it would
just like tell you to get off the
highway not however like just a main
road yeah for like one minute to go via
like a round in a field and then join
back and it's like why for one minute
it's like why would you why would you
think i'd want to do that i'll just stay
because google's like we know you want
the scenic route because it generally
wants you not to be on a main road which
is good because sometimes it took us
down some really cool
routes yeah because we trusted it but
other times it would take us down a road
maybe just gravel and we couldn't cycle
on it right because the bikes the roads
yeah i i remember i encountered this
problem a lot in uh thailand yeah oh god
yes because
because what what what i would do is you
know
google maps you know works in thailand
but what counts as a road on google maps
google maps can't tell you the quality
of the roads
google maps use like open maps and open
maps is from like i don't know like
government i don't know yeah i don't
know because like what happens is uh we
we'd like when i was living in thailand
me and city would like have a
destination sometimes it would be like
an hour away or something like a
different town and goo and we'd be on
like the highway with signs telling us
to lead to this town or the city that we
wanted to go to and google was like no
take take the exit off here and one time
we're like okay why is it telling us to
take the exit off maybe there's maybe
there's a shortcut we don't know about
and then so we went from this very
well-lit road we take one exit off and
google leads us to it's it's
the definition of a road was pushed to
the limits okay what it led to was
not even like concrete it was just dirt
leading into a dark forest
and there wasn't we couldn't even go
back right because time in the country
yeah first time yeah because it was like
it was like it was on a mountain right
it was on a mountain so we couldn't even
you turn back so we we were forced to
like go into like this pitch black
forest and i was like i'm gonna get
murdered this is this is literally the
start of every horror movie i've seen in
my life you know you you follow google
maps you're like oh okay what's this uh
going a bit to the country this is where
the serial killers live man this is like
texas chainsaw massacre all over again
we had that though uh yesterday when me
and nabi went we were in shizuoka
yesterday for a shoot and like we were
trying to go to this like you know
because like for the most part it's like
country sign shizuoka yeah and we're
like i want like a really like nice spot
to like shoot this part of the video
and so we were like alright we'll put it
in google maps and then i was like okay
go down this road and i was like okay
that's fine we get to it
first of all it's a one-way road in
between two houses
barely can fit the car that we have
and it's not even the right way
and the google maps is like do it
go there is no other way to go down to
your destination go down this road right
now and we had no choice because there
was like cars backed up yeah yeah
literally no other road to get through
this part i'm like
why are we going down so what you want
us to like break traffic laws to get to
our destination thanks google
it's so annoying it's so annoying and
it's like and when you try and be like
okay we can't go down this road can you
try something else they're like okay how
about you go around the block once
and try it again
i was like no girl
i don't want to go down this road i
think for all the information they take
from us to yeah maps accurate they at
least do a [ __ ] good job
like it's like well it's because not
enough people are living there further
yeah there's no information to take
you know for the the comfort of having a
map that could tell me where to go i'd
like to think that you know you taking
everything about me and using that
information to serve ads to me least you
know at least i got a good map out of it
like google's that one mate that's like
sitting in the passenger seat being like
yeah don't worry about it
don't worry about it it's the quickest
way to go it's like are you sure yeah
yeah yeah i know this place
don't worry it's down there this video
is sponsored by boxer huh
i'm feeling a bit peckish all of a
sudden do you have anything to eat
before this
no and i'm in dire need to satisfy my
hunger before we record this trash taste
episode worry not connor because i have
the exact thing for you
a boxy box
tell me more joey boxer is our favorite
japanese snack box they work with family
businesses all over japan and send you a
new theme of authentic japanese treats
every single month and for this month's
boxu theme we have the otsukimi harvest
meme
otsukimi or moon viewing festival where
families gather to express gratitude for
a good harvest joe which one do you
recommend which one which one should i
try out jeff uh these are actually
pretty good these are some yucky
tomorrow
uh barbecue porn chips
oh god i don't mean to be corny
gentlemen but that's pretty good
so if you want to try some rare japanese
snacks and support this channel then go
to the link in the description and use
code trash taste 15 for 15 off your
first purchase back to the show one
thing i've got to mention is that yeah
having a car that rides with you is very
opie and cycling oh yeah definitely
because you don't have to worry about
like water or anything it's all taken
care of you're still talking about the
back of the car shout out to the chance
who just do it all themselves i don't
know how you do it
well their backpack is probably insane
yeah
they don't have the tech on them so they
can fill up with actual uh things needed
uh to uh
to keep their body going right yeah yeah
exactly i guess so
stopping at conbinis and then there's
like none in north hokkaido as well yeah
true yeah true so sorry to talk about
just the cycling so much i guess i just
[ __ ] all i did was that for eight
days yeah that's all i could think about
i'm just i'm just trying to think like
what i did during those eight days it
just seems like oh we went to the
cigarettes concert
oh [ __ ] we did that was last week what
the [ __ ] oh what concert
we went to so garten and i went to uh a
concert of a band that we both really
like siguros
you might know one of them okay what was
that one song that was like really big
in like british tv that you told me
about this hobby potluck oh that was
awesome yeah yeah i think apparently i
didn't know this because god told me
there's like one secret song that got
really [ __ ] massive because japanese
friend no no no no icelandic bands oh
yeah yeah it's a nice landing how does
that song go again uh hoppy paul yeah
that's this is the problem with
cigarette songs all the song titles are
in icelandic so if you don't know
the name of the song you're just like
what was that one song the one that's
like
and they're like are you singing the
halo theme oh oh no it's like a beta
yeah [ __ ] amazing like probably one
of the best concerts i've been to in my
life yeah yeah i think it was the best
concert i i went to in my life i mean it
was there are some i think bands that
work better in a live setting and i
think sega ross is one of those bands
that i've experienced them now live and
i can't imagine experiencing them
anything but live yeah you know
absolutely because it's kind of like
they have such a very
of unique style right because it's not
like it's not like your typical kind of
songs kind of like rocky songs it's very
i don't how would you describe it joe
you're the music guy i'm having trouble
finding words like i've i've always said
said to say uh like to people that like
cigarettes music is kind of like
it's like advanced
church hymns
do you know what i mean
it's like because it's like it's the
feeling of like when you listen to a
church him right yeah you don't have to
be religious in any way but the sound
and the style of a church him is like oh
this is like i can understand why they
play this kind of music in churches
because it's like it's very
transcendental it's very like yeah it's
like
religious you know but like it's very
like pure and like transcendental and
very like it gives you that feeling of
like oh you know this is very spiritual
yeah
and cigarettes is like that but like
the alpha version of it yeah yeah
basically
it's
i don't i don't really know how to
describe their songs i can just describe
what it means to me and it's every time
i hear a sega ross song it just like it
makes me emotional it makes me feel
things that i can't explain going to
going to the going to this concert and
hearing their songs i was processing the
experience for like a full like for the
entire night after that you know you
know what i mean yeah i get that i get
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the live show's so good yeah yeah
what did i just watch yeah i remember
turning to joey and being like i'm still
like processing what we what we just did
yeah
like i didn't even know how to do it it
was definitely like it wasn't the kind
of like shows where you're like in a
mosh pit and you're like freaking out
and then afterwards you're like damn
that was [ __ ] awesome that was so
hype hell yeah it was more like the ones
where you just like you're sitting down
quietly after every song finishes you're
clapping and then the next one kicks in
and you're just like engrossed it's like
a full body experience and like with
some of their songs like oh my god like
those like speakers that they had at in
this hall they were working overtime bro
like you could feel this yeah just
pulsating through your body and you're
just sitting there like a 4d movie just
like yeah like just taking it all in
because you don't know what else to do
yeah it's crazy oh my god it was it was
so amazing i mean like could have been
like indoctrinated or something because
that was just like how absorbed i was
into this experience you know it was
just one of the most it was the most
incredible concert i've ever been to i i
still i'm processing it to this day yeah
i do not know how to describe beeps and
boops it was very nice
you know it's lightning in the bottle
man you can't explain that no it was
just i get it i get it
you it's it's impossible to explain how
a gig makes you feel yeah yeah i i made
like a second channel video like trying
to process it but like even then it was
just kind of like
yeah the entire time i'm just like it's
so hard to describe without you being
there to experience it because there was
one part i think one of the most
powerful parts in this like oh i think
it was like what two and a half hour gig
or something it was it was quite a long
like three hours almost three hour game
what made you want to make a video about
it if you couldn't really explain it
because i i don't know so like one of i
think the most amazing parts about
cigarettes music is that like it they
utilize silence silence to their
advantage
to like create this like tension in
their music so there was one part in the
in the concert where
in the middle of the song
they just stopped playing
and they were just standing there in
silence for about 30 to 40 seconds
but the thing is like a little fart in
the background no no dude i've never
heard that was probably what like it was
full capacity right and this place can
hold about eight thousand eight thousand
people big hole right in order and i've
never heard 8 000 people being that
silent in my life there was not a single
person talking or making noise during
this like 30 40 seconds of silence and
it was the most intense moment i feel
like it was longer than 30 40 40 seconds
right because you you had i think i feel
like everyone had the same kind of
experience where they stopped the song
and you're just like okay must be moving
on to the next one yeah and then you
know when someone holds a silence for a
bit too long it starts to become
uncomfortable so they held it past the
point of uncomfort that you you
discovered that it became it went from
uncomfortable silence to comfortable
silence it was such a [ __ ] surreal
experience it was if i had to put into
words it was the loudest silence i'd
ever heard in my life yeah right i'm
just like that's that's the best way i
can describe this because it was one of
those moments where you just like kind
of forget to breathe and then once the
music kicks in you're like oh yeah
that's right now i know where i was sick
and and and it's so cool as well because
they utilize these like lights in such
like
cool ways so like during this silence
there's just this like kind of yellow
light that's just like pulsating
just silently
and it's just going on and on and on
they're not moving at all not a single
note and everyone's just sitting there
just like waiting
and it was the it was the weirdest
feeling it was so cool i've never seen
any band do that in a live setting and
i'm just like the the balls to be able
to do that and everyone just immediately
know exactly what's happening being like
this wasn't like a mistake or anything
this was just part of the show yeah so
definitely ten out of ten would go again
oh [ __ ] you uh hell yeah ten ten hour
[ __ ] ten out of ten yeah easily and
i've been to like a lot of really
[ __ ] cool concerts but like just this
one was like
it was more like watching a stage show
if anything it wasn't like going to go
see a band it was like if you it was
like kind of what you feel after you've
seen like a life-changing movie mm-hmm
what what's a life-changing movie for
you well i don't know like batman yeah
being like god they're boring
can never look at batman the same ever
again
but like you know you know there's those
movies that just kind of like on a
personal note that just like viscerally
hit you to the point where
after that
your your standard of movies just change
yeah yeah you know so if like for me for
example like the first i remember like
the first time i watched like pulp
fiction you know like before that i was
like oh you know movies are cool and
everything and then afterwards there's
just like there's one of those movies
where you just watch it and you're like
how do you go up from there
you know and i and everyone has you know
a movie or you know maybe some people
haven't discovered that movie but like i
feel for me
that cigarettes concert was that
but for concerts yeah okay so like i'm
afraid to go to my next concert because
i'm like because like it might be just
go to a really [ __ ] one yeah it might be
[ __ ] great it might be a band i've
always wanted to see but i know in the
back of my mind there's going to be that
one little voice that's like you know
it's not as good as the serious concert
is it
you're going to be chasing that high for
the rest of your life absolutely yeah
because i i know even because i was
obviously out there at the concert as
well
i i was i was there too i was there too
guys guys don't forget about me i was
there life-changing concert guys what
can i say my life was also changed guys
okay do you think okay do you think
there are films that you experience and
you might you might watch right and
there's a d there's a big difference
between
films that are basically made for the
theater and films that can just be
watched anywhere because i i feel like i
didn't
because i i didn't really understand the
whole like cinematic experience and this
is gonna be sounding really cheesy but
the the first [ __ ] movie that made me
feel that was [ __ ] your name man just
like [ __ ] i i know guys i know your
name your name never you'd never watched
a movie for your name no no no no this
could be improved in the cinema
yes
what yes
i i had never seen a movie in theaters
that just made me go wow that was that
was going to [ __ ] up that table
for me
because
for me that was a cure
when i saw when i saw akira in cinemas
when they redid it for like i think it
was like the 20th anniversary of the
25th what was this
this was like four or five years ago
none of you had ever watched a movie
before that and thought damn this would
be so good in the movie no no what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
okay because i i kind of but the thing
is i kind of my excuse for that was
because my dad is a massive film buff he
put so much money into like the home
surround system still not going to be
it's not going to be the same
for me i'm like this is good enough yeah
but but like for me i i've the cinema
has always been haha bigger screen
louder sounds cool
the way you view music is the way i view
films no because it's like your tv is
[ __ ] all the colors and all the [ __ ]
is wrong it's not what they they wanted
it to look like it it looks exactly the
way supposed have you have you tried
watching some movies on your tv at home
it looks like [ __ ]
uh most films i watch i feel
you know when when one when i saw
anybody when i said
silent green they didn't know those
people
know it's people when i talk when i talk
about like when i talk about cinematic
experience i don't mean cool you know
this would this experience would be
improved by watching in theaters because
ninety percent of the time okay yeah
okay it wouldn't be you're implying okay
no are you saying like your name was the
first one of me you think i i have to
watch this in the cinema where i'm like
this can only be enjoyed in the cinema
like to to me no no
no
to me to me it's something like
something like your name and i feel like
what's the newest mummer her soda feel
whether it's like it's like having a
meal at a an ubereats or a restaurant
it's like it's it's like always meant to
be at the restaurant and yeah you can
have it there no not every film not
everything i think i feel like 90 80
percent of films are just way better in
the cinema do i watch weathering with
you in cinema when it came out and then
i watched it again at home kind of the
same experience
i can't say but like you know like a
quentin tarantino film like every one of
those should be watched in the cinema
well i never watched paul fiction in the
cinema yeah i never noticed one of my
favorites but like anyone that comes out
now i'll try my best to watch them in
the cinema right like i i feel like most
films are just so much better in the
cinema because it's like it's like the
way that they they every single aspect
of the the creation process was with
that screen and that that you know that
size and the the colors and everything
was all that right that exact
specification is it's weird because like
you wouldn't change a you know like when
they reprint the manga it's not like
different right it's on the it's printed
the way they want it to be printed
exactly when you read it right but with
the tvs because they all have their own
[ __ ] settings and all their own color
settings i'm sure you've gone to your
friend's house one time and thought who
the [ __ ] did your tv settings it's like
the contrast is [ __ ] ridiculous okay
so whatever iteration is blowing maybe
i'm that guy because i've never thought
that they probably just
they probably just put it on [ __ ]
movie mode and thought that's it that's
for me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait hold on can people put it on
anything but the default settings unless
they have like a home cinema set because
i've never yes yes i've always just put
it on default oh my gosh i've never
changed my default settings from my
twitter oh the default is bad it's so
some tvs right they like add frames okay
no no okay like that pisses me off okay
that's a different story
he's doing this [ __ ] like all your tv
that wasn't an issue before smart tvs
that was i noticed that i was i was like
why the [ __ ] does this look off because
we bought like everything was in 24 fps
i'm like this looks too real
it's like i just don't i don't subscribe
to them i'm like this this gay gamers
have made a
time i've ever seen the colors are
[ __ ] too i don't know
i guarantee you your colors are [ __ ]
on your tv and when you change them
you'll be like i'm an idiot but you
don't know because you just like
watching it yeah but i also don't watch
movies that often yeah right if you're
not watching movies
i i i'm not even talking i'm not even
talking about movies i'm talking about
any form of media really because like i
remember your games your game call is
probably wrong
like your pc monitor i don't really yeah
you don't you don't care until you know
and then you're like god damn it like
this game was more beautiful because
like you can get these devices that uh
point at the screen yeah
ghost of tsushima looked beautiful on my
default setting tv
it could have looked even more beautiful
you can get these devices on your pc
right because
when you're editing thumbnails yeah
don't you want to know that the
thumbnail that you're editing is like
the right color because you might be
editing it on your monitor which is
wrong colors and you're sending this
thumbnail out and it has different
colors yeah but i'm okay because i
guarantee the majority of other people
who look at that are probably also
looking at it so they're defaulting so
the idea is that if you have your
monitor on like uh the like most default
kind of the the flattest color profile
um that you know when it gets to an
iphone when they change the brightness
it goes to samsung they change the
brightness that like you don't you're
not like doubly skewing the
the messed upness to it if that makes
sense right you don't want it to be
[ __ ] on both ends you want to be the
correct thing on your end so when it
goes to someone else's device that's
that's wrong that it doesn't look
completely messed up right
because i noticed that uh i used to used
to have like one or two of my thumbnails
really weird on some of my friends tv
and i was like huh and it was because my
colors on my monitor were like it was
the manufacturer's default which is
awful awful like i had an msi monitor i
don't know how they messed up the colors
on this monitor so much it was so bad
right so so bad and it was just like i
don't know how to i was what's the right
color i don't [ __ ] know so you just
buy this device point it at the screen
tells you what to do
i'm gonna be real dog i've never done
that in my life
i've never once noticed but it's like
having it's like having a
[ __ ] pair of pants or something right
you just don't know it's [ __ ] until you
get a good pair right a lot of the time
i don't know just like you don't know
it's bad
to me to me my life you don't know
you're cycling on a ship bike until
someone points it out in the comments
that's just how it is it's like it's
like yeah it'll do the job
you know maybe you want to kind of get
it better i mean i i hope i can see
color just fine i think i can i've never
i don't know that's red right that's
purple right yeah
that's why we have like this set to like
you know a certain color profile so that
it looks the same on every this device
this is why i'm not a cinematographer or
like i hate working
with like cameras because i just like my
brain just like doesn't process it it's
the same with filming right we filming
this thing so that when it goes to
everyone's [ __ ] up tvs that hopefully
because we filmed it correctly it
doesn't look as [ __ ] up on that tv
right right no because what okay because
you'll notice on some screenshots
from people say picture their tvs
sometimes trash tastes way lighter
sometimes look way darker
i've never noticed
i'm not gonna lie dog
dead ass it's little things never
noticed
i just you know we just wanted to look
good i don't look at the details in my
brain i'm like are we recording yes or
no
if it's yes good if it's no bad this is
like the opposite of beeps and boops you
know yeah it really is
bits and bobs if you make a [ __ ]
movie it belongs on the big screen and i
can't believe that it took your name and
acura for you to watch them even going
ah yes big screen good i don't know
because like there's there are still
like
you're telling me this you're telling me
james [ __ ] cameron's avatar like was
dog [ __ ] on a tv that movie was only
watchable on a cinema like experience
also it was pretty it was amazing it was
a movie
even a movie like that that was like mid
there's so so much better
because here's here's the thing right
here's the thing yeah
i'm not i'm trying to find a way to
describe this because you know watching
let's say og interviews of like steven
spielberg and you know hearing some
directors talk about
the art of filmmaking and you know
cinema and everything they'd always talk
about the magic of cinema this feeling
i'm just like i'm like i'm like growing
up i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about magic of cinema bro it's
gonna be like a generation of people who
don't go to the cinema this is just a
marketing point
i'm like i'm like you're just trying to
sell tickets just tell me you're trying
to sell it
because you're trying to tell me
yourself it's got too expensive like
going to the cinema is expensive like
yeah
yeah it's like you know who the [ __ ]
wants to pay to go to all this [ __ ] all
the time yeah i could just watch it at
home for free
what i'm saying is watching your name
i'm just like oh i get it that's the
magic of cinema yeah i get it now
because like i remember when your name
came out everyone was just like oh
silent voice is better southern voice is
better and i'm just like well and you
know technically i think sun voice has
is has a better plot you know and you
know better written characters but if
you're gonna tell me which film i'd
rather watch
in cinemas well silent voice is
basically an extended tv program versus
your name which is i think
a story that was made to be displayed in
theaters yes whereas silent voice i
think you you know the enjoyment
obviously will be increasing theaters
but i don't think you're losing too much
by watching it on your tv or something
like that you know that's that's kind of
what i mean that's kind of what i'm
saying where there are some films that
make you feel this magic of cinema and i
thought it was just marketing [ __ ]
there's a lot of films you feel like
yes this had to be experienced this way
yeah and like us ever since then there's
been like a few more films like
especially like seeing the avengers in
cinemas as well that was that was
something that i think
lost loses his edge not being
experienced with everyone else at the
same time in cinemas sorry joe you know
you've missed the bojo you've missed the
boat yeah
not that i was going to catch that boat
anyway
i don't know i think maybe it's just
because i i you know i go to the cinema
a lot and i enjoy it and i i really i i
treasure that i experience a lot it
means a lot to me see but like that's
the thing it's like yeah for you that's
cinemas for me that's live shows yeah
right it's like same same same idea just
different executions because to me what
it sounds it's like you're to me it's
like the same way i've been as being
like just listen to the album why do you
gotta go and see them live yeah exactly
like it's like it's like i would never
like it's it's like of course 99 percent
of music
sounds way better in a live setting yeah
exactly yeah i must say like auto-tune
to [ __ ] and then yeah yeah but i don't
listen to that
yeah the majority of music or media is
there's a there's a yes of course the
best way that you can enjoy why why is
why is things enhanced by it being live
you know whether it'd be like [ __ ]
twitch or with like live shows as well
it's because it's the communal communal
aspect feels like you're in on it
because
you know you you hear about people talk
about live shows and you know you know
something you say is like oh you have to
be there you have to be there yeah yeah
and it sounds cheesy but like you've
like when i go to live shows i find it
so hard to verbalize the feeling and the
experience i felt
within that live show versus
experiencing that same piece of media
that same music that same show on a cd
or like or or something else
what sets it apart i mean i def i mean
when it comes to like music stuff like i
feel definitely some genres just work
better in a cd setting obviously
compared to a live show or like they're
not noise that much
well yeah i mean like i guarantee like a
lot of ambient music is probably gonna
sound and feel the exact [ __ ] same
right live or not but like but i think i
think when like musicianship is involved
with like multiple people or even like
one person and just like the energy you
feel in that room that you're like oh
i'm experiencing this with everyone else
yeah i can see the magic being created
on stage like in person you know it's
the difference between like
i don't know uh [ __ ] seeing a
painting on a wall versus actually
watching the artist paint that same
painting right like you'd much rather
see the process being done rather than
just experiencing the result right
because
every live show i've been to i'm sure
you can agree with this as well it's
like yeah it's it's been way better live
seeing it live oh yeah especially like
musicians and stuff like that especially
if they're good musicians like yeah a
hundred percent maybe if maybe they're
like part of the brain that's like mob
mentality right where it's like you just
you feed off the crowd and being a part
of it yeah definitely being in that
energy you feel like you're
oh my god i can feed off everyone else
getting hyped and i feel like it all
just builds yeah we're weird creatures
yeah
i don't think lions get hyped about
other lions
oh no man they seem to hype each other
up
like yo without hunting the [ __ ] dude
i mean they hunted but i don't know if
they're getting like they're feeding off
each other bro when they when they spot
that elk in the distance they're like
i think it's like a quirk of our
evolution
into the idea of being a part of
something big well yeah it's the
difference between you know a caveman
dancing around a fire on his own versus
a caveman dancing around the fire with
other cavemen well yeah it's like i if i
miss a game a league of legends whatever
game or a football game which i don't
watch yeah you know i i'm never going to
go back and watch the vod i don't know i
don't know i'm like i want to i want to
feel you want to be there be there live
yeah know that everyone's losing their
collective [ __ ] when something crazy
happens right that's part of the fun
that's why like yeah like as much as i
love the live show experience and
watching musicians do stuff live that's
why i very rarely unless it's like my
favorite band i very rarely watch like
live dvds or like live footage i hate
listening to live concerts and cds i i
just yeah well it depends how they're
recorded obviously if it's on a [ __ ]
iphone then it's going to sound like dog
[ __ ] yeah yeah but like some some
professionally recorded like live albums
and stuff like that they can sound
really good but it's like
i'm only listening to that because
that's the best that i have because i
wasn't there when it was actually yeah i
don't know but if i was there when it
was recorded i'm not going to
listen to it i actually think live
recordings okay okay here's
you've just unlocked like a memory i
guess where if i have the choice to
download a studio recorded song or a
live recorded song where i can hear the
audience reaction i always go for the
live recording really yeah because i'm
just like damn it just
makes the music sound better and i don't
know why i agree it's like a different
energy yeah yeah yeah i just like the
idea that it's kind of like an art piece
where it's like you have designed the
perfect thing that you think this is not
yeah can you perform it every perfect
every time or whatever yeah but maybe
the roughness of performing it live adds
more character too oh yeah i think it
does hearing you know not sometimes you
you hear like an offbeat note or like
cause something's slightly off tune or
something like that you know like maybe
a voice
i feel like that adds to the music to me
and
hearing the perfect studio version isn't
always like the best experience for me
yeah yeah i've never thought about that
yeah when when i tried it like on my
spotify playlist i try to put as many
live performances as i can
i hate them yeah i do i think as long as
like maybe with some exceptions like
some live albums that are like
exceptionally well recorded other than
that i don't normally listen to live
versions because it's like i would
rather listen to this
actually in person like i don't want to
live vicariously through a crowd i'm
listening through spotify no no
it's not like it's not that i don't want
to be there of course i want to be there
but like if i if i if i have a choice if
i could cope i'd be like
if i close my eyes i could pretend i'm
there okay i can pretend i'm there i say
this knowing that like deaf punk had
that live album which was sick yeah yeah
but that's because that was so well
recorded that was right and it was also
completely different to anything else
yeah
that was crazy but if it's the same song
as the studio version i'd rather listen
to the studio if i can have around the
world without people chewing in the
background i'll just take that one yeah
but the map
makes the song so much more the mashup
version is sick though yeah yeah because
it's different yeah yeah the defunct
live album was okay that's an exception
that's just mashups yeah it wasn't the
same song yeah because if the contents
the only time i would re uh i would
listen to a live album is if the
contents is something that i can't get
off any studio mm-hmm then it's like
then that's just like new music yeah
right and so it's like hell yeah
kind of builds in and then the hype kind
of builds into it right because it was
built off of that but if it's the exact
same song i'd rather just go to their
concert see tim to me the crowd
just by having a crowd there you're
adding like an extra light we should
have a crowd trash taste episode that
would be interesting
we need a live studio audience trash
takes is filmed in front of a live
studio audience
shout out to our live tour by the way
let's see what the tour is going to be
come come see we need to we need to
start the tour we need to start every
tour with this is done
yeah but like if we do another tour just
every time we just got to start it off
with this this show is performing in
front of a live audience
i'll do that i'll be the guy i'll just
do it he should just slap bass
yeah i don't know it's it's weird how
just adding an audience to something
just makes it incredibly more hype for
me it's it's like everything except for
sitcoms i [ __ ] [ __ ] hate like
worse the water
i absolutely hate when sit come remember
this when sitcom went through it like
it's canned laughter phase and sometimes
it wasn't even canned laughter sometimes
there was an actual live studio audience
i like to argue that's still happening
is it in a lot of ways the best one
yeah that's not still gone going is it
is that i thought
big bang theory is still not gone i'm
sure though they're still i'm sure
they're this is this are they still
making episodes
that's what i thought
i'm sure there's still a bunch of
sitcoms we just don't know about that
have canned laughter including so
because now that's just like a staple of
sitcoms now did frasier
yeah frasier had it friends malcolm in
the middle no
didn't have it oh really yeah yeah it
didn't have it also wait what's the one
i'm thinking of
uh two and a half minutes
in the middle was amazing what's what's
the most popular sitcoms nowadays
because you know i i look at sitcoms now
i'm like i never always
barely ever watch
brooklyn nine-nine that doesn't have
canned laughter yeah yeah cause it's
like because i i've i feel like
it's very very popular yeah am i crazy
is that the most popular one i don't
know i'm not sure
all right most successful sitcoms what's
the most popular one most popular right
now
yeah yeah because like i remember you
know back back in the day we'd have
things like friends
you know friends and um
like frasier and other like super mega
popular super mega popular sitcoms like
that and you know not to say that it
weren't funny but
i it seems like sitcoms now are going
through a phase where they've just
removed the can laughter and i'm like
thank [ __ ] thank god for that because i
feel it was like such a rare occasion
where adding canned laughter to a sitcom
actually enhanced the comedy like in my
head i think the only two shows that i
thought were like genuinely watchable
and funny at times that had canned
laughter was probably friends and i t
crowd
like other than those two shows i'm just
like
it's just it's just like it's i don't
know it's mocking
where it's like please laugh now you
know it's like i actually that's the
reason i didn't like it crowd really it
was that one show everyone's like [ __ ]
this this is amazing it's so funny it's
really good i think it's really history
i think it's one of the rare exceptions
where it was like the comedy itself was
actually so funny in a lot of episodes
where i could ignore the candle after
right you know but like there's a lot of
shows like say like big bang theory
where it's like the jokes are like
subpar at best and then the it's like
the canned laughter is like laugh now
where it's like it's instructing you
when to feel emotion and i'm like no
that's not how comedy works well that's
just like the thing that i could not
stand on my camera and why i couldn't
get into the i.t crowd is because what
can laughter does is that it [ __ ]
messes up with the pacing of the comedy
or the show because people have to pause
it's literally say a joke pause for
laughter right and and you basically
subconsciously telling people okay this
is one to laugh right whereas when i see
something funny and happening in real
life you don't [ __ ] pause for
laughter well i'm not pausing every time
okay well then what about like every
like stand-up comedy show every star
that's also a big reason why i've never
been like
you don't like stand-up content i'm not
a fan of stanford oh really yeah i love
stand-up comedy yeah i'd much rather
watch stand-up special over any sitcom
to be honest um because like for one
it's not candle after it's yeah it's
real it is real laughter but there's
also they still do that thing where like
a lot of their jokes are designed where
they would say a punch line and then
they would pause to leave enough space
for the crowd to hopefully laugh at the
joke right and i feel in a lot of like
really good stand-up shows i mean i'm
not a [ __ ] stand-up spo uh you know
expert or whatever but like i've seen
enough where like i've noticed a pattern
where a lot of the best comics they
purposely make the joke flow to the
point where that pause that they add
between a punch line and the next thing
they're going to say it enhances the
comments yeah yeah and it's like and i
feel like that's no different to how
like shows like it crowd or friends did
it where like the the joke is usually
structured around the pause
but like there's a lot of shows like say
big bang theory it's just like it
doesn't really work because of the flow
of the conversation it just really seems
unnatural i have this weird relationship
with stand-up comedy actually because
it's it's been like this way my entire
life where you know with cam laughter
and with you know being filmed in front
of a live cd audience if i feel like
they are telling a joke my subconscious
brain just goes you are playing a you
laugh you lose challenge right now you
know
so you like the dry humor i oh well yeah
i [ __ ] love dry hair
i am british i also like dry humor but
the iot crowds are my favorites yeah
yeah yeah because yeah okay but then
here's the question have you ever gone
to see stan will call me live i haven't
no i haven't yet it's good i i feel the
one where it's like the live aspect
makes it a million times i can i can i
can i can i can see that yeah because
when you're in an audience then you kind
of want to laugh yeah i've never asked
this are you guys musical guys do you
guys like musicals i like musicals
yeah i
enjoy i wouldn't say i'm a musical guy
i'm not like an iceberg but i like i've
seen a lot of music yeah i've never been
that guy who's like gone out of his way
to go see musicals but every time i have
i've just had like a brilliant time i
don't really like musicals
oh i thought you were gonna lean on
being like i love musicals let me talk
about it musicals you know what any
musicals
there's always that one because my my
hands down that's enough my hands down
favor will always be rocky horror
pictures so you're gonna ask what are
you gonna say like les miserables
that the only one you've watched no i've
watched um
okay i haven't liked everything
i've watched that i've watched book of
mormon yeah that's a great great musical
watch them on movies well that's
probably what
i hate musicals and movies as well i
sing i hate when they sing i don't want
to see i want to see a story i want to
[ __ ] hear them sing i think i think
again the only musical movie that i
really enjoy was rocky i love plays i
love watching plays live i hate watching
people sing live like like i'm not in
like a concert setting
i actually like i i hate musical in film
forms you know i heard musicals i'm so
when it's in stage form that's actually
the only times i've ever liked it
i can appreciate how like how talented
and how you know how much work goes into
it yeah it's very demanding but i just
don't really like it yeah i love plays
yeah yeah i think i think i know i i
think i understand your hate for like
musical or like musical numbers in too
many beats and boobs it just feels like
it like rips you out of the
like the flow right now i get that i
think i think that you feel that way
because for the most part the storyline
itself is like very serious and it's
told in like a cinematic yeah yeah and
then all of a sudden it like cuts to a
musical right yeah which is just like a
polar opposite but that's why i think
rocky horror was such a great movie
because that storyline does not take
itself seriously okay the entire time so
it feels
less jarring when it goes into a musical
number because the non-musical parts are
just as [ __ ] ridiculous
so like but like that's another big
reason why i like i mean among many
reasons why i like the cats movie
[ __ ] sucked right yeah because like
for one it looks horrible but two it's
like a serious story right that just
looks goofy yeah and so that goofiness
is just enhanced when it goes into a
musical number yeah which sucks because
if you see cats like on a live stage
it's [ __ ] amazing it's it's such a
great musical life
like which is why i was so i mean which
is one of the many reasons why i saw the
trailer to the cat's movie and i'm just
like oh god why did you do this it's so
bad it's like it's like it's like seeing
the trailer to like the worst
live-action anime film you've ever seen
yeah it was really really it was it
feels horrible what about like films
that have been turned into musicals have
you ever like experienced that i heard
that back to the future one was okay
it was a back to the future music
there was a back to the future one
apparently it's pretty good i saw the
death note musical
damn that sounds fun
i felt like i was on drugs while i was
watching that show i'm like this is not
a real thing i'm watching because it's
like
again going back to that whole like
adding musical numbers in a very serious
storyline like you can't get more
serious than a death note storyline
right and then all of a sudden light
just like busts into this musical number
of how he's gonna kill every criminal in
the world i'm just like
i knew you were a psychopath character
but now you sound even more like
actually
you know i can actually kind of see it
yo yo you you you hear else theme you
know what the [ __ ] doo doo doo doo
doo and you think that's that's a
[ __ ] fat beat you know you yeah but
like that okay i understand if you're in
a musical setting you hear the else
theme and then it like busts into a trap
beep and then they just start dancing
live on stage but that's not what
happens
theme goes so hard are you kidding me
that that [ __ ] moment where the
guitar kicks in
bro that that was made for a musical man
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying yeah it's it's uh it's a
really fascinating i actually really
want to go see more like anime like
musicals just because it's
one of the most unique
entertainment
cells at work one as well i remember
that yeah there was a prince of tennis
one as well there was a free one
uh they did a lot they have my hero
oh my name is
[Music]
chocolate factory that was good it was
really good musical numbers in it
the gene wilder one yeah that's what the
musical number in it has numbers in it
like um oh oh yeah i guess i guess some
other has some other moments where it's
kind of musically yeah
yeah i wouldn't say it's traditional but
yeah i think the reason why that worked
is because the story is just so
ridiculous yeah that it just matches
that world yeah yeah
it's like you know
death note you guys watched any like
traditional plays live i was actually
going to say like i tell you what
this weird rabbit hole i've fallen down
in recently
uh i've been watching like clips of
rakugo
oh dakugo is fantastic yeah yeah
rakugo is like a traditional style of
japanese storytelling it's it's stand-up
it's original stand-up comedy yeah yeah
it's it's like they're not standing up
yeah they're literally like sitting down
you take stand up right and you just
restrict basically everything so
you're not allowed to like walk around
you have to sit down in one tiny spot
and all you have as a prop is a fan and
that's it
and using just that they have to convey
the story which isn't always funny
sometimes it's like serious story
but
that's that's all you have to use to
like convey the story and so there is
down comedy yes it's stand up comedy
this is a sit down comment yeah but the
reason i got into it was because i've
been i had to read like i kind of uh is
it akane banshee banashi
which is like a new shonen jump a manga
yeah
so that that got me really interested to
be like okay yeah i know how they
portray in manga and everything but how
does actually look in real life and i've
never just like appreciated just this
[ __ ]
it's really is like an art form of
storytelling because we've just like
such
you see with like such
subtle changes in expressions and
mannerisms they like these rocket
performers are able to just
absorb you into this story into this
world with just like very subtle changes
in their face and just their mannerisms
and i'm like this is [ __ ] incredible
like i should not be this invested in a
story where this guy's just sitting down
with playing around with the fan yeah
yeah i don't know
it's almost like it's weird it's almost
like cause i've been to a rocco show
before because my grandma's really into
it um and it was really weird because
like even if you don't fully comprehend
like say the bot of the joke or the
point of the story is that the intention
of the book yeah the bot of the joke
like you know like the the the joke
even if you don't comprehend like the
joke or the the meaning behind the story
or whatever like it's still just
enthralling to watch it especially if
it's a really good performer yeah yeah
to just sit him sit there and it's like
he's just like writing a book in front
of him yeah and you you can fully
envision everything he's saying and just
get like engrossed being like so so what
happened after that yeah it's it's like
when you go to like a [ __ ] family
reunion and you just have like that one
uncle who's just really good at
storytelling and it's like i might not
even care half the time about what the
actual story is but i just want to keep
listening of like that it kind of brings
you back into that zone where you're a
kid and your parents would like read you
like story time books or whatever and
you're like oh well what happens next
what happens next you know
i kind of like that same feeling but
just as an adult and uh yeah i never
would have like got into it if not for
like anime and manga and it was just
like i'm surprised it was that one and
not raku shinjuku that got you into it
okay cause like i i think uh i i watched
raku shinju and that's
i felt more focused on the drama aspect
yeah where this is more like okay let's
take rakio and just shown shonen shonen
it's shown in fire shonen fire i was
trying to make a word out of it but it's
like this this this actress who this
performer who wants to be the best
racket performer of all time and you
know that should they have like
power-ups
[Music]
no they have like training arcs
in our basket
you can rotate this thing 360 degrees in
0.1 seconds
basically that's how the guests like i
can throw
hemorrhoids now he has to become a
stand-up comedian like no he has to like
slightly lift his butt on me
oh my god it enhanced the story
oh my god yeah so that was like i would
love to see a raccoon performance live
because if i got that engrossed watching
a youtube video which is normally i hate
watching what live performances on
youtube then i
i would wonder what it would be like
being in that room and just hearing
hearing the performer actually do it
that's that's the kind of the same with
like kabuki or like normal you don't
always need to understand everything
yeah yeah
yeah yeah honestly i i i speak english
and i watch shakespeare and i didn't
know what was happening but i had an
amazing time yeah i i think that
if you go to london you should watch try
and look to see if there's a shakespeare
performance oh i want to watch a show
live i've never seen like a shakespeare
story live dude in the globe it's
[ __ ] awesome yeah uh unless you're
standing or a polls blocking your way
all right there's some seats that are
sold as like a pole that's blocking your
view
because it's traditional
because it's it's literally a replica
because you just have to like kind of
[ __ ] literally yeah you literally
have to just
the whole time wow sometimes some
traditions shouldn't be kept
tradition so the building burned down
right yeah they remade it one to one and
yeah if you want to stand in like the
pit you stand there like four hours
standing below the stage looking at the
stage because that's how you get you get
the peasant experience you literally get
the fastest except you're paying for it
yeah it's very cheap though down on the
bottom yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's really really affordable these
things unless you want them like really
i thought to myself i've been in enough
mosh pits while i'm standing up for
hours at a time where i could probably
do that but like it's kind of like being
in a motorsport but not moving yeah yeah
you should go it's just like this
is that like they only have them like
three four times a month and they're or
is it like they're always booked yeah
and it's it's never the
shakespeare story you want right i got
super lucky one time i got hamlet yeah
it's my favorite one um but every other
time i've been it's been like one of the
shakespeare ones that i i don't really
like as much
yeah i think i would only really be
interested in going to see like my
favorite one which what's your favorite
one macbeth macbeth is good
i like i like the tempest as well
temperatures uh a few other ones i like
this
classic
yeah but like definitely going to that
cigarettes concert made me miss
live performances and going to see live
performances so much where like i mean
obviously worst timing to like plan my
next live show because i'm leaving
yeah we are the live streams we are the
live show we're gonna go do a live show
well technically you're getting a live
experience joey you're just on the other
side of the floor
yeah sure i'm just like can you record
for me so i can like watch it later
but hey look at all these patrons though
wow amazing yeah
amazing wow
sorry sorry you guys can't enjoy the
live this is this is not trash taste
live but uh hopefully one time we can
enjoy a live show you can come to the
after dark streams that's live yeah
that's the closest you're going to get
the closest you're going to get if you
missed out on the tour
but uh if you'd like to join the patreon
and support the show come over to
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you had our face listen
to us on spotify and yeah follow after
dark there's your live experience yeah
exactly and i guess that's it for this
week we'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]
you